there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey everybody out there
episode 178 going back to true crime
after the paranormal stuff we talked
about last time I actually thought that
we had done this show but we had yet I
can't believe we haven't done this one
it's I was thinking about the other day
like all the serial killers that we
haven't got around to doing yet a lot
like holy crap there's like some kind of
big-ticket ones that we haven't John
Wayne Gacy never did it yeah we haven't
done John we games kind of done Ed Gein
yeah it's like I put him on the schedule
like for the next couple of months but
uh this right here is gonna be about
Gary Ridgway otherwise known as the
Green River Killer yeah although I'm it
was Ed Gein just a serial killer
officially did he kill enough people I
think I kill one did it one or two yeah
he was mostly just a wearing a
necrophile yeah which you know Gary
Ridgway had a little bit of that going
on - um interesting thing about this
case one I believe if he indeed did do
all the crimes that he was charged with
and convicted of that he confessed - he
is actually the United States most
prolific serial killer with 49 yeah
although he admitted to killing as many
as seventy one and it wouldn't shock me
if that was the case you know he was
operating for a very long time like
before they caught him and he seemed to
like do a lot in a short span of time
you probably know how many he killed I
don't think he does and I think he said
that at some point I believe he's still
alive he's in prison in Walla Walla
Washington yeah but um he said on
numerous occasions that he had lost
count
yeah and like I said I believe that he
wasn't going for a score he was just
trying to get off yeah pretty much yeah
so it's interesting because
you remember a couple weeks back when I
said you know our friend and fan of the
show Sophie had sent me this book the
gates of Janus that was written by
Moore's murderer Ian Brady now he
actually has a chapter in here where he
talks about the Green River Killer
however when he wrote this
it was early 2001 and Gary Ridgway had
not been caught yet so when he was
talking about the Green River Killer he
was talking about someone who had not
been caught right so it was like kind of
interesting and I you know I'll probably
get into a little bit later too but Ian
Brady believes that there was more than
one killer operating it in the area at
the time and that Gary Ridgway did kill
a lot of them but that there was someone
else there was at least one other killer
too because some of them modus operandi
were mowed I am we're slightly different
but I don't know it I mean a couple of
the investigators on the case they
speculated that there could have been
more than one killer like operating the
same area just using similar dumping
grounds or maybe one was a copycat of
the other one I don't really know if
that's the case or not I should remember
that but yeah because like a couple of
the victim profiles were different a
couple of the you know modus operandi
were different but I don't know it
didn't seem different enough that it
would have been 2k I mean because serial
killers like I said are pretty rare
anyway and to have two operating at the
same time period in the same area seems
far-fetched not impossible but
far-fetched it was a long time ago that
I saw the particular program I'm
thinking of but I saw one where an
investigator or a cop actually pointed
out a couple of clusters of bodies that
they had found in that same general area
but they they seem to have come from a
time when Ridgeway was could not have
been active that was like one of the
things that I kind of remember but it's
a long time ago I just remember thinking
that there was some of those bodies up
there I remember you know cops putting
forth pretty good a pretty good case
that he couldn't have
nose yeah but you know that was a good
place to hide bodies that's why Gary
Ridgway did it yeah there was there may
have been more than one out there but he
wasn't doing exactly what Ridgeway was
doing it's just where he was putting the
body yeah and I mean and I'm not saying
that Gary Ridgway didn't kill a [ __ ] ton
of people cuz he did yeah um you know
what I mean it's not like a case where
you know like Henry Lee Lucas or
something like that who killed maybe
three people but then like confessed to
like 600 I was I don't think it was
anything like that where Gary Ridgway
said yeah I killed you know 50 60 70
people and he didn't do it I think he
did yeah killed that many yeah I'm
unscripted I don't ennis all from memory
maybe somebody in the audience might
remember the exact details
I do remember a cop point not a couple
of those body clusters and he was saying
Ridgeway couldn't done these and I don't
remember exactly why I think maybe he
was out of town or wasn't there yet or
something it was something the audience
might remember the exact details all
those bodies they found that he didn't
do them all but he did most of my thing
I think he didn't do and I'm like I said
I wouldn't be shocked if he did do them
all because I don't know I'm like how
likely is it the two serial killers were
operating like I said in the same area
during the same time period like I said
not impossible it happened in you know
you know it Arab Toronto Ontario it
happened oh it's happened but it's I
don't know there was like a couple of
parks that were fated that were famous
like leak leakin leakin Park is one of a
leak in part you can park is one of the
more it's famous a famous body dump a
body dumping boy yeah they just fight
you know and it's outside your urban
area semi deserted if you have a body to
dump that's the place to dump it and
they've been dumping them dumping there
for decades well look at something like
the Texas killing fields um you know
that one kind of stretch like off those
two two or three major highways where
they know for if I mean they find bodies
there all the time and they know for a
fact because they've caught some of the
killers that that's definitely several
killers yeah probably truck drivers
because they've caught a few of them but
it's like they know that like they'll
catch one and they'll be like okay what
he did you know these three but then his
DNA doesn't match like these other 15
over here
I mean so it's like it's not the same
person it's several people using that as
a dumping ground which is kind of
terrifying I think we did a show about
Texas there's only been a couple
confirmed truck driver serial killers in
the United States but most people agree
that that's a likely job for serial
killer that would be a killer because
they're always moving yeah they're
always moving and like I said you know
it's you know they're not they're
driving through places and like people
wouldn't recognize them because it's
like you know they don't they kill a lot
lizards and there's no connection to
them yeah exactly um so you know for
those of you people outside the United
States a lot lizard you don't know that
is a lot lizards is a kind of a slang
term for a prostitute that specializes
in the rest areas or you know where the
truckers hang out yeah a lot of those
yeah so before we kind of get into
talking about the Green River Killer
case which has a little bit to do with
Ted Bundy as well later on I'll enormous
was a lot lizard what she I believe she
was yeah there's all it was all damn
truck driver said yeah yeah okay um
let's do a couple of shout outs
got a couple patreon shoutouts to do I'd
like to say thank you to Justin for
increasing his patreon support so thank
you very much Justin I also like to say
hello and thank you very much to our
newest patron who is named Tammy so hey
there you guys thank you very much any
support that you guys can give us is
much appreciated even if it's not even
monetary support could be just sharing
the videos telling other people about
the show stuff like that we're trying to
grow bigger almost to eight thousand
subscribers on you do so we're we're
kind of excited about that we've been
averaging like a consistent 200 subs
additional subs per month I think right
yeah
about 200 a month yeah um you know so
any little bit helps yeah if you guys
share and recommend and talk about us
and you know then you know in the
comments sections on other people's
videos send them our way people yeah
everything helps it does indeed all
right so I don't say did you have any
other shoutouts that you wanted to do I
can't really think of anything else at
the moment other than you know I'm glad
everybody seems to be liking the
witching hour shows that I've been
putting
I have like a few more of those to do
and then I'm gonna start recording new
ones that that's more popular than I
thought it would be yeah I'm kind of
surprised yeah even though you told me
you did some research and other channels
that specialize and nothing but that you
have millions of views yeah some of the
[ __ ] well because a lot of people just
like to like you know on your commute or
like when you're getting ready for bed
or whatever it's cool to just like lay
there and listen to creepy stories yeah
it was a good idea so you know it's like
your mom reading to you for you yes you
want me out here manic seemed in the
comment section I want me to read yeah
you should you gots a reason well that
will have to like um I don't know I'll
have to think of some great face why I
mean I'll pry start busting out laugh at
his funny [ __ ] that might make them fun
freedom has myself and you'll be like
reading isn't slow haven't you'll be
like oh yeah probably all right so uh
let's start talking about the Green
River Killer case now like I said for a
very long time I mean the crimes that
you know that Gary Ridgway later ended
up confessing to started in the early
1980s like right around 1982 he was
actually not caught until 2001 even
though he had been on the police radar
he had actually been picked up for other
things like tangentially related to the
case but they never had enough like
evidence to get him so it took him until
2001 like when DNA got good enough to
link him to several of the murders and
he subsequently confessed like I said he
confessed to initially 48 and then he
confessed to another one so they add
another so he is actually um he did that
to get out of the death penalty so he
got essentially 49 life sentences you
know so he's never getting out obviously
although I believe he is still alive I
think he's 70 years old right now so
let's go back to August 15th 1982
there's a guy named Robert Ainsworth and
he is rafting down the Green River which
is near Seattle Tacoma Washington State
and this was something that he did a lot
you know kind of rafting down this river
whatnot so he's going down the river and
he happens to look over the side of the
boat and he sees a face floating like
right beneath the surface of the water
it was a black woman now initially he
thought it was a mannequin which I know
that's terrible but I always kind of
makes me laugh because every time
because I read about true crime cases
all the time and it's always kind of
like oh we saw this thing on the South
Road and we thought it was a mannequin
it's never a mannequin / - it's always a
dead body so I mean I'm sure sometimes
it's a mannequin but not in this case so
he thought it was a mannequin and he
tried to like I guess snag it with the
pole and then horribly he ended up
appending the boat and falling into the
water at which point he realizes this is
not a mannequin but a dead body not with
it I know and not only that but a few
seconds later he sees another dead body
like right there so there's two of them
like right in this one area they're both
young black women so of course he
understandably he freaks out he swims to
the river bank and he was there was a
truck there earlier that he had passed
and like he had talked to the guys but
they were gone now so he kind of they
didn't have cell phones in 1982 so he
sits there in the bag kind of like
wigging out
these two kids combined a bike and he's
like hey you know can you go get the
cops I just found two bodies so the cops
come and they find the two bodies and
then they start you know kind of
cordoning off the area and looking
around and everything like that
at which point they found a third body
this one was actually found not in the
water it was actually found on the
riverbank about this less than thirty
feet from where the other victims were
this girl was a bit younger than the
other two she had actually died from
asphyxiation there was a pair of blue
pants or jeans like tied around her neck
that that had she had been strangled
with she had bruises all over her arms
and legs suggesting that she had
struggled with her attacker
this girl was later identified
as sixteen-year-old Opel Mills they
thought she had been dead about 24 hours
so it was fairly recent so they were
fresh yes and he was dumping them all
there in that same area at that period
they were all black yeah so he was going
on a black binge it's not yeah because I
mean I think it was just whoever he
could find some of the victims were
black majority were white white yeah but
it just seemed like whoever he could
pick up most of them were prostitutes or
teenage runaways although some were not
which is what made some people think
that maybe this was more than one killer
you know what I mean because some of the
victim profiles were different so that's
kind of a point in that in that other
theories favor so they eventually ended
up identifying the other two victims as
Marcia Chapman who was 31 years old and
Cynthia Hines who was 17 both of these
women were had were known to be
prostitutes Oakland Mills was not she
was just like a regular sixteen year old
girl so again that's knocked her into
his car yeah it's not the quite the same
victim profile the two women that were
found in the water actually had
pyramid-shaped
rocks stuffed up their vaginas um
they're not entirely sure if that was
done like as a sadistic like a
ritualistic type of thing or if he was
trying to wade the bodies down obviously
that did not work because they were
still floating there so I don't know
that just seemed like a really weird
detail Ridgway it wasn't a real bright
guy uh he was not he had a pretty low IQ
yeah but that's pretty weird he did that
yeah and some of the other bodies were
found with like some strange like kind
of ritualistic aliy posed type of stuff
he did go back and screw him after they
were dead rayray anything maybe that was
some kind of like sex toy he's putting
over there felt good that yeah some
people have speculated that it might
have been
as well that it might have been some
kind of weird weird thing and you know
he's hitting that rock in there
yeah which weird who knows I mean you
know and as met as much interviews and
stuff like that as they've done with him
like you said he's not I mean he was
smart enough not to get caught for all
that time but he's not the brightest
bulb on the tree so he didn't really
seem to have a lot of insight into why
he did what he did right you know what I
mean it seemed very surface level like
when they asked him about it and I was
even like I watched like a whole bunch
of documentaries about him and stuff and
even a lot of the investigators and
people that had interviewed him said
that too they just said you know it's
like I don't really think he knows why
he did what he did he was just basically
like oh I hated them and I didn't want
to have to pay to have sex with them so
I just killed him right like it was the
most natural thing ever it was just like
yeah you know it's funny is that he was
probably a little smarter than all of us
Henry Lee Lucas yeah those two seemed
really they were even dumber yeah and I
there's this just when you look at
ridgway's case this is this is Conte
this is what a dumb serial killer can do
they can rack up a score pretty high
like 40 50 something like that
well yeah yeah under the right
circumstances but there's no way Henry
Luke Henry Lee Lucas could have killed
those hundreds of people well yeah we
were talking about that when we were
reviewing that documentary about him
it's just like you know been caught he's
too dumb yeah and you know they even
determined that his lie that there was
no way that he could have been like in
all the places like I said and even on
that documentary when they had like they
drew a map and like this is what he
would have had to do in like X amount of
time like every year all the way over
there all the way over there like
there's just no way yeah I do think he
killed those three people though right
so um Marcia Chapman he was 31 years old
now she had been missing for two weeks
when they found her she had two children
now she had been dead for over a week so
she so she had been in the water the
longest because she was quite decomposed
Cynthia Hines had only been in the water
for a couple of days and as I said Opel
Mills had probably been on the bank for
less than 24 hours so these were not all
dumped at the same time this was like
over a period of a week or two and it's
funny he's dumping them all
I shot from each other yeah and see him
yeah well later on when they asked him
about that he said that he liked to dump
a lot of the bodies and clusters because
then like when he was driving back you
know back and forth and he would like
think of the cluster that he had left in
there and it kind of like made him happy
thinking about it okay you know what I
mean so you know even if he didn't go
back to like revisit the bodies you know
he just liked the thought of all of them
back there right you know which is why
he probably couldn't explain it that's
what I mean he didn't really seem to
have a lot of insight into why he was
doing it he just did it because you they
just do want to talk about it yeah
now interestingly these were not the
first bodies that had been found in the
Green River several days prior to this
they had found the body of a woman named
Deborah Bonner
she was actually she was found nude and
she had been found slumped over a log
she had also been strangled to death and
a month before that another young
teenage girl named Wendy Coffield was
also found strangled and floating in the
Green River six months prior to that
there had been a body of a woman or a
girl named Liam Wilcox and she was found
a few miles away like in an empty lot
now the Green River Killer they do not
think killed Leanne Wilcox they think
that was somebody else but it's possible
that it's possible she could be
connected to the case as well because
like I said this is I guess this is kind
of like a remote area and it's possible
that there's more than one killer
operating so and a lot of the girls like
I said we're Runaways or prostitutes or
something like that which you know they
that's a very dangerous profession so
it's possible that some of these were
killed by other people so they don't
think that
liyan Wilcox was a victim of the Green
River Killer however they do consider
Wendy Coffield and Deborah Bonner are on
the list of official green Green River
Killer victims so within six months
there have been six bodies found in the
river or near the river so detectives
obviously know that they have a serial
killer on their hands and kind of tried
to pull out all the stops in order to
catch him so they assemble a special
task force to investigate the Green
River murders now this was the largest
Police task force assembled in this area
since the Ted Bundy investigation the
Ted Bundy murders which had taken place
about nine or ten years earlier so they
you know they had all I kind of all
these big names and you know there
worked on the Bundy case and all this
other kind of stuff were you know on
this particular task force now
apparently the investigation was kind of
stymied from the start they had like a
whole bunch of information coming I
presume there's a lot of bodies like
found in a brief period of time they had
tons of different tips and they didn't
really have I mean it's only the early
1980s they didn't really have a good
filing system they didn't have you know
it means they didn't have like any way
to process all of this information that
was coming in because and because there
was so much of it like some of it was
overlooked some of it was lost you know
what I mean and it's like they had to
get like volunteers to come and help
them like go through all of this stuff
and all those other kind of crap so
while they were investigating detectives
figured out that a lot of the women that
had girls and women that had been
murdered knew each other even if only
vaguely most of them like I said had
worked as prostitutes or were Runaways
and were running away from like abusive
households and stuff like that you know
they so they had that kind of you know
rotten start in life
so they decide that they're going to
start looking around what's called the
strip or the SeaTac strip seattle-tacoma
which is where kind of a lot of the
prostitutes hung out it was very near
this Seattle Tacoma
International Airport so there was like
a lot of hotels bars stuff like that and
you know it was a very you know it was a
place that prostitutes were known to
frequent so they figured they would
start their investigation there and
hopefully someone had seen whoever this
was that was picking these girls up so
they start interviewing like all the
prostitutes that work this same strip
you know at first it was a little bit
problematic because uh you know
obviously a lot of prostitutes don't
really want to talk to the cops
understandably so you know it was kind
of hard to get information out of them
however when they looked back through
some of the older records and stuff like
that they did find some police reports
that had been filed previously by
prostitutes that kind of seemed
significant to the case so they had
interviews with two separate women both
of whom had worked as prostitutes and
they said that there was a man in a blue
and blue and white truck had abducted
them and tried to kill them now the
first of these women was named Susan
Widmark she was 21 and she said that
this guy in this truck had come up he
was like a middle-aged dude she said she
got in his truck and once she got in
there he pointed a pistol at her and
then sped off down the highway so he
takes her to like this you know out of
note like you know this road out in the
middle of nowhere he turns off the
engine and violently rapes her then he
after the rape like he told her to get
dressed again he started to drive away
from the scene with her still in the car
now while they were driving she told the
police that he had talked about the
Green River murders which is you know
what made her like think that maybe he
was like related to the case now he was
still like holding the gun to her head
the whole time however when he stopped
at a stoplight she jumped the [ __ ] out
of the car and while the car was
speeding away she was actually able to
get part of the license plate
um now a similar thing had happened to
another prostitute Deborah st's it was
only 15 years old now she had actually
filed a police report in August of 1982
and said that she had been walking down
the side of the highway when a
middle-aged man in a blue and white
pickup truck had approached her and
offered her a ride she got in and then
the same thing happened that man pulled
out a pistol pointed it at her drove her
to a remote area and raped her
and then like he released her into the
woods so the taskforce thinks that this
dude could be the Green River Killer
white truck and both of them yeah both
of these and it was the same MO like
they both got in the truck he pulled out
a gun out and took him somewhere raped
them and then let them go so so the cops
start investigating this guy now only a
month later like after Deborah estie's
had reported the rape in September this
butcher named Charles Clinton Clark he
was pulled over in a blue-and-white
pickup truck driving along Seattle's
main strip they did a background check
on him and determined that he owned two
handguns
so they figure okay well maybe this is
him they get his driver's license photo
they showed it to both of the victims
and both of them identified him yes this
was the man that abducted and raped them
so this guy gets arrested and they
search his house in his car they found
the two handguns that you know the women
identified as the ones that had been
used in the assaults they questioned the
guy and he admitted that he had indeed
abducted and raped these two women so
even though like they were kind of
thinking well maybe this is the Green
River Killer but he let them go he
didn't really seem to want to kill them
he just was like a rapist which you know
that's bad enough but so you know what I
mean so the mo wasn't really the same
and when they kind of investigated later
on they found out that this guy
you know when the green river victims
had disappeared
this guy had like a solid alibi like he
was at work or he was out of town or
something like that so they knew that he
couldn't have been the Green River
Killer although he was actually charged
with the rape of the two girls now while
he was being um arrested there was
another woman a 19 year old Mary Meehan
she was taking a walk and she
disappeared now this girl was about
eight and a half months pregnant at the
time she went missing near a motel along
the strip so she actually probably had
been working as a prostitute as well I
mean that hotel that she was coming from
was kind of like a known prostitute like
a place that prostitutes would take
their clients but she was just out
walking very heavily pregnant and she
disappeared
so at this point they're like okay well
maybe the task force is like maybe one
of the because they had like a bunch of
civilians to come in and help with the
task force with the case because they
had so much information and they said
maybe one of them is the Green River
Killer because from from the profiling
that they you know the kind of that they
had kind of done on who this guy might
be they were like well this seems like
the kind of guy that would you know kill
people and then want to get involved in
the investigation like to see what was
going on and where they were going with
it so they started investigating like
all the volunteers that had come in to
help out the task force with the Green
River Killer investigation so at this
point they find this guy who I guess had
been volunteering to help them and this
guy was a taxi driver he was 44 years
old and what ended up happening with him
was that he seemed to know a lot of the
victims because I guess he had worked as
a taxi driver like on that beat and they
thought it was suspicious that he knew
so many of the victims and
so they kind of started like looking
into that guy now two weeks before Mary
Meehan had disappeared there were these
two 16 year old girls named KC and Leigh
and Terry Renee Milligan and they also
mysteriously disappeared both were also
Runaways and had had a history of
prostitution as well so they were also
believed to have fallen victim to the
Green River Killer
now this taxi driver that they were
interviewing John Douglas the FBI agent
very famously he was one of the guys
that came up to was kind of like
instrumental in establishing the FBI's
Behavioral Analysis that perp the
profiling lab so he had actually drawn
up a profile of the Green River Killer
and the taxi driver seemed pretty much
just like that um you know because the
profile said the Green River Killer will
be a middle-aged man he will be
confident yet impulsive he will probably
frequent the murder scenes either to
reenact the crimes in his mind or to
revisit the bodies he said the killer is
probably familiar with the area we'll
probably have deep religious convictions
he also thought that the killer would
probably have would be really interested
in police work
had eather tried to be a police officer
before it was like kind of a cop groupie
you know and thought that he might
contact the police to try to help them
out in the investigation so since this
taxi driver kind of had a lot of those
you know attributes and also like I said
knew a lot of the girls that had gone
missing and that had turned up dead
because he had worked along the strip as
a taxi driver they kept a pretty close
eye on this dude so throughout the
winter of 1982 they pretty much kept him
under constant surveillance even though
he was pretty adamant about saying that
he was innocent and he just knew these
girls because he had given them rides
all the time and he had kind of gotten
to know
and like be friends with them and stuff
like that so he was you know very
adamant that he was not the killer
eventually that they couldn't they
didn't have any evidence to you know to
pick him up for the murders or anything
having to do with that so it they
arrested him on some unpaid parking
tickets that he had just so they could
have him in custody so they could like
figure out if he was the Green River
Killer or not but they could find no
solid evidence tying him to the murders
even though he did actually know five of
the victims now September 26th 1982 they
find another decomposing body this is 17
year old prostitute named Giselle love
Warren now she had been missing for two
months before somebody on a bicycle or a
hikers and looked at found her nude body
near kind of like a neighborhood of like
old abandoned houses near the SeaTac
International Airport she had been
strangled with a pair of men's black
socks now we're they said weirdly when
she disappeared like the last time she
was seen she had blonde hair but when
they found her body her hair had been
dyed black so they're not sure what at
what point that happened so even though
she was actually found by the airport
and not in the river or like a rug right
around the river they thought that this
was probably the same killer just
because the modus operandi was the same
the victim profile was the same now
between September 1982 and April of 1983
14 girls disappeared now among those
that disappeared very interestingly one
of them was Deborah estie's the 15 year
old that had reported the rape by the
other Clark guy and she disappeared okay
as did 13 other girls and young women
all between 15 and 23 years old most of
whom were known
constitutes or were teenage runaways now
so the task force they this this is kind
of interesting at this happened and they
talked about this a little bit on the
documentary and this is like kind of a
shame that they didn't [ __ ] catch
Gary Ridgway at this point because this
was still back in the early 80s so what
ended up happening was this girl named
marie mal VAR now on April 30th 1983 her
boyfriend who was also kind of like her
pimp he sees her talking to a potential
client who was in a dark colored truck
like cuz he like looked out for her you
know he was like behind while she was
like soliciting clients and stuff so the
boyfriend sees her get into the truck
and then the truck speeds off now the
boyfriend said it looked like Marie and
the guy driving the truck were like
arguing so he got kind of worried so the
boyfriend started to follow the truck
now I guess the guy who was driving the
truck realized that this other guy was
following him and like took the [ __ ] off
and ended up losing the boyfriend the
girlfriend Marie subsequently
disappeared so her boyfriend reported
her missing to the police now a few days
after this incident Marie's boyfriend
and her dad were driving around the area
trying to see if they could see this
truck so they could figure out where
Marie had gone so they find they see the
truck driving around the same one so
they follow it to this house on south
348 Street so they call the cops so the
cops show up at the house knock on the
door ask is this your truck and guess
who answers the door it was Gary Ridgway
however he denied having anything to do
with Marie mouth or the disappearance or
anything like that and the cops left it
at that hmm they just left well I guess
they knew where he lived
yeah but this was this was 1983 they
didn't catch him if you're doing the
math until 2001 yeah but they went to
his house and asked hey do you know
where that girl is because her boyfriend
says that you got she got into your
truck and then she disappeared he's like
nope don't know anything about it the
cops were like okay bye have a nice day
they didn't have enough to do any kind
of convictions or make an arrest it had
to be I guess not
but yeah it's just like I saw that what
jurisdiction was this again this is a
Seattle okay right around Seattle but
it's hard to believe that all that [ __ ]
was going on in Seattle back in the 80s
all these you know Runaways and underage
prostitutes and [ __ ]
yeah that's not everywhere in the United
States cuz it's only in certain trouble
spots
well it's any of you any big city yeah
or outside cities that are crumbling
yeah addling economies and stuff I mean
that doesn't really I mean that's not so
much you know she that doesn't hear that
doesn't explain well yeah but we live
kind of like in an upper-class
neighborhood yeah well even well even
you can go on the other side of Orlando
and and that's not really going on
airline drive that isn't going on that's
where all the hookers are well I think
there's underage hookers on airline
drives I don't think the cops are
tolerated I don't know about that yeah I
mean I think some of that was going on
in Daytona yeah and I'm sure it probably
goes on in Orlando - it's just you don't
see it just don't notice it as much you
don't notice it because you don't you
know it's not like you're down there
like soliciting the [ __ ] as far as I
know so it's nice to be in special
places where only the underground knows
yeah maybe I don't really know but yeah
so I miss all you drive around see it no
yeah well and nowadays you probably
wouldn't as much anyway just because of
like they do it online online and stuff
yeah that so you wouldn't see it as much
I wouldn't assume you do it over their
phones yeah probably yeah so yes so that
was kind of the shitty thing they did
actually go to Gary ridgway's house
because you know because they had
recognized his truck but he said he
didn't have anything to do with it and
they couldn't you know they didn't have
a warrant or anything so they couldn't
go in there
so another prostitute also disappeared
in April
this was a girl named Kimmie Chi Pitzer
now her pimp also saw her getting into a
dark green pickup truck with an attached
camper he said he kind of got a look at
the driver he said he had a pockmarked
face he saw the two of them drive off
and then he never saw Kimmie again he
did report her disappearance to the
police but for some reason the police
didn't really link the two crimes I'm
not entirely sure why so at this point
spring of 1983 all of these girls had
disappeared all of these bodies had been
found and the investigation really
didn't seem to be going anywhere they
were still looking at the taxi driver
but like the longer it went on they were
kind of realizing look it's probably not
this guy you know they kind of kept him
as a prime suspect at the for the moment
but it's like they you know they were
getting less and less confident that
that's who the killer was you know no
new leads were emerging prostitutes
still kept disappearing and it seemed
like they couldn't do anything about it
the task force was having a hard time
like keeping up with all of the new
information that was coming in and all
this other kind of stuff so it seemed
like it was all kind of collapsing and
no one was you know nothing was getting
done and everyone seemed like they were
getting really frustrated and everyone
was getting very angry at them like the
public was getting very angry at them
there was a lot of speculation I don't
know if this is entirely fair but a lot
of people in the public and especially a
lot of women that worked as prostitutes
were saying the police didn't really
give a [ __ ] because the victims were
prostitutes and if it had been you know
other types of women that like maybe
they would have tried harder I but I
don't know about that because I have
seen like interviews with people that
were on the task force and they did
genuinely seem to be I mean they're like
we were trying our hardest there was
just so much information and it's like
we didn't you know we didn't have any
leads we didn't really know what to do
and it's like everything was really
disorganized
and it seemed like they were really
frustrated by
the whole thing when you tried that when
you're dealing with prostitutes and
trying to do an investigation happening
in the world of prostitution those cops
are always at a disadvantage uh-huh too
many goddamn suspects none of them
connected to the girl yeah they don't
even have the crime scene they may have
the body where it's dumped but don't
even know where it happened yep
maybe happened in somebody's car they
don't have the crime scene so you you
can't locate who did it yeah so like I
said I mean all this well there it's
just because we're hookers I never buy
that I mean if the company would anybody
behind bars that they can yeah I get
that damn arrest credit yeah and it's
it's just and it really did I mean
particularly in this case like I said it
really did seem like the people that
were on the task force were really
really trying and we're really upset by
the lack of progress on the case but
like you said they're Japanese
milliner's dudes car is [ __ ] 10 15
times a night you can't figure out which
one of those guys I mean and if serial
killers particularly that target
prostitutes or Runaways or you know
hitchhikers or something like that you
know not only is there no connection
between the killer and the victim but
it's like sometimes the witnesses yes
sometimes there's no witnesses it's like
sometimes the women were run away so
they lived alone they sometimes they
were never reported missing
he's an idea right and some indeed some
of the victoy believe it's four or five
of the Green River Killer victims are
still not identified because they were
already skeletons by the time they were
found so it's just a really sad
situation all around and it's like you
know yeah you can blame the cops for
doing some dumb things and actually when
they did do you know kind of like an
analysis you know Bob Keppel who they
brought in to kind of try to codify
everything and like try to put
everything together he actually was
quite critical of like the way the
investigation had been conducted so far
you know so so there was some [ __ ] going
on a both sides but I don't think it was
anything to do with them being like not
caring about the victims or anything
like that I think it was just regular
they were just overwhelmed with all the
number of murders that you know and just
the number of
the number of witness statements the
number of suspects it's just lying it's
all in consequential [ __ ] no that points
to a damn suspect right and like
assessing that one this one that one
this one that one but then you
investigate there's nothing to
investigate you don't even know where
they were killed yeah it's just all dead
ends so no and you have to look and you
have to investigate everything and it's
like there's only so many people and you
know you never know like what is gonna
be important and what's not gonna be
important so you have to like look up
everything so I can understand you know
I'm not like the biggest world's biggest
fan of cops but I'm just saying that in
this case I do think they tried their
hardest it was just that circumstances
intervened that you know they [ __ ] up
it's like everybody [ __ ] up and it
sucks but that it took so long for them
to catch him but [ __ ] happens I mean -
and this was like the early 1980s it had
the Internet they didn't have cell
phones they didn't have like all the
[ __ ] that all the you know forensic
techniques that they have now so it was
much more difficult for them they were
coming at it from like a you know a big
disadvantage you know yeah so I can't
blame them entirely even though like I
said when I saw that [ __ ] in the
documentary about how they actually went
to his house and we're all just like oh
well I guess it's not him because he
said it wasn't it's like that just kind
of made me mad so so like I said Bob
Keppel the guy that they brought in to
kind of kick him in the pants like kind
of like get the investigation back on
track get it together and stuff like
that he actually ended up writing a book
later on called the river man and he
kind of made recommendations for like a
bunch of different changes that would
have to be made he's like because he's
like everything was just a complete mess
it's just like there was I don't even
remember how many people were on the
task force but it's just like they were
all over the place it's like you know
they were all trying to do everything
like all at once he's like so one thing
he's like one thing we need to do is
kind of like get all these cases
together like put all the similar ones
together and the dissimilar ones
together and he's like assigned each
person like their own task instead of
just everybody trying to like do all
different types of things he's like
that's just really disorganized so he'd
have like one person sorting out
forensics
and one person you know interviewing
prostitutes and one person like keeping
track of all the suspects and one pursue
so everybody's had their own job which
wasn't being done prior to that so like
I said it was kind of really in disarray
so so yeah this investigation was
costing like millions and millions of
dollars and like I said the public was
getting really really annoyed about it
um so May 8 1983 yet another body was
discovered this was 21 year old Carolyn
Kristensen
she was actually found in a wooded area
near Maple Valley by a family who were
out looking for mushrooms
um this is another case where cuz
remember the first bodies that were
found was like rock stuck up their
vaginas okay this girl was found with
her head covered with a brown paper bag
they took the brown paper bag off and
the killer had put a fish on top of her
neck like had placed it there he also
put another fish on her left breast and
left a bottle between her legs her hands
were crossed over her stomach and on the
top of her left hand was like a little
pile of freshly ground beef isn't that
weird uh she had also she had been
strangled with a cord or to get the beef
I don't rub Eve I guess I must been
cooked beef it out of something that she
had uh well yeah but it was like on top
of her hand
like what hurts like that and like he
put out like it was ritualistic put some
little taco meat on there that's like
it's like a fish they're in a fish a
fish on the neck and a fish on the boob
and he put a bag over her head yeah it's
just a weird some weird [ __ ] he's trying
to be artistic I guess yeah that's you
know I was trying to be artistic is that
[ __ ] for guys just um the weird thing
about her body was that even though she
was fat
like on land it looked like her body had
been in the water for a little while
beforehand like they'd been in the water
and then had been taken out and left
there maybe you washed her it may be but
um I don't know I'm I don't know if they
can tell I mean I I'm pretty sure they
can tell if the body's been in the water
for like an extended period of time or
if it's just like a washing thing he
probably washed her but it was really
weird cuz this was like miles away from
the river so hmm it just seemed very put
her in a car yeah I guess so took her
out there yeah so spring in summer of
1983 nine more young women many of whom
were prostitutes disappeared most of
them were between the ages I believe the
youngest was 15 and the oldest was 22
did some of them though it's like most
of these were put on kind of the list of
they had like a list of like official
Green River but then they had some that
were not put there because I guess they
had established like a parameter for
like where the bodies could be dumped
it's like the ones within this parameter
are the Green River killers but ones
outside of that weren't which to me
seems a little arbitrary because it's
like you know cars or a thing yeah and
and and if Gary Ridgway did actually
kill all of the people that he said that
he killed because they found a few
bodies in Oregon and he did later say
that he had taken them to Oregon in a
car like and dumped them there like in
order specifically in order to confuse
the police so so like I said I don't
think that the fact that they were found
outside of these arbitrary bounds of
these are in in here or the Green River
Killer murders like I said I'd be more
willing to listen to it if the modus
operandi was drastically different but
if you're finding bodies like within a
state or two that are killed pretty much
exactly the same and it's the same
victim profile and stuff like that I
think chances are it's probably the same
killer and they're just driving farther
afield in order to confuse the
investigation I mean that's what I would
think
how many active serial killers they had
at one time in that state true I've
heard that was it each state with you
average in one or two yeah probably
which is kind of horrifying to think
that I mean you know states are big and
everything but it is kind of scary to
think that there's like one or two of
these [ __ ] like in every state
yeah Florida's probably probably got
more than our fair share I would thank
[ __ ] Florida man somebody Florida man
about it are you I'm not really hurt not
really I haven't I haven't really heard
about I mean they're still around
obviously but I think they're an
endangered species yeah you just don't
hear about and we've talked about this
before you just don't really hear about
it in the same way that you used to I
don't think I don't think I don't think
with the environment you that creates
these guys as around anymore yeah so
it's less likely that they appear now
some some guys that we've known that
we've been on other shows they said like
well maybe the serial killers going away
but the mass shooter has taken its place
I said no it's a totally different
psychology it is that is a totally
different the mesh the masked type
shooters and the mass killers have
always been there it goes all the way
back hundreds of years yeah it's just
that the tools that they use were
different and a lot of it has to do with
high school high school environment yeah
I mean yeah it's kids [ __ ] with each
other and then one of them blows a
gasket they're not locking him up like
they used to if they used to lock him up
yeah you know but um okay so like I said
there's kind of like their finding of
this alarming like number of bodies and
some of them are considered Green River
Killer victims and some not so much as
the summer of 1983 went on several more
bodies were discovered in June they
found a set of unidentified remains
thought to be a 17 to 19 year old white
woman August 11th they found a woman
named Shonda Summers who had been
missing for quite a while she was one of
the ones that had gone missing like
during one of the earlier rashes of
disappearances they found her near
SeaTac Airport also near SeaTac Airport
I believe it was the following day they
found yet another
which I believe at this stage is
unidentified fall and winter of 1983
they also there was a bunch more
disappearances and a bunch more bodies
so between September and December of
1983 nine more women went missing and
seven bodies were discovered all of
these were considered to be victims of
the Green River Killer again these were
mostly prostitutes or runaways the ones
who you know I have all their names and
stuff like that but it just seems like I
don't want to like do this big long
litany of them but they did find some of
the bodies that were found 17 year-old
Delores Williams she had actually been
missing since March 8 1983 she was found
at Star Lake they actually ended up
finding because like I said the first
victims were Green River then there were
some like by the airport there were also
several found in and around Star Lake so
they found Delores Williams and then the
same day they found another body in star
lake of Gale Matthews who was 23 years
old
the next few months five more bodies
were discovered this is a lot of bodies
yeah I mean you know what I'm saying
this is a lot of people October 15th
they found these skeletal remains of
Yvonne Ann Tosh she had gone missing on
May 31st she was actually one of the few
victims that had had a missing persons
report filed on her as I said a lot of
these women were prostitutes and so were
not reported missing 12 days after that
they found a partially buried skeleton
of a woman named constants constants
neon and she was also found near SeaTac
Airport so what they decided to do was
they said okay well since we're finding
so many bodies in this one area they
said we're gonna like spread out they
got the [ __ ] teenage Explorer Boy
Scouts out there to help him out they're
gonna do this big huge search to see if
they could find any more bodies around
the airport and indeed they did find one
Kelly we're 22 they found her skeleton
covered with trash underneath
some bushes like one of the Boy Scouts
found her before the year was out two
more bodies were found November 13th
following a search of several Lots
surrounding the area south of the
airport they found Mary Mahan who had
gone missing several she was the eight
and a half months pregnant woman who had
gone missing several months before these
were the only victims her and her unborn
baby were the only victims that were
entirely buried some of the victims were
partially buried but most of them like
they were usually like in the water or
they were just kind of dumped or just
like covered up with leaves or something
like that but she had actually been
buried they actually found like some
kind of weird things around her body
like a couple pieces of plastic they
found this big clump of hair like near
the pubic area of her body they found a
patch of skin attached to her skull that
had fibers on it they found three small
bones which presumably were not hers two
halves of yellow pencils and some clear
plastic tubing so I don't know what all
that [ __ ] was used for but they found
that with her body as well
December 15th they found the skull of
Kimmi Chi Pitzer who had gone missing
several months previously she was found
near Mountain View Cemetery so it seemed
like this was um the fifth dumping
ground so cause like I said he liked to
dump the bodies in he called them
clusters yeah and this was actually the
fifth cluster that they had discovered
pretty much every time they found one
body if they spread out and looked
around they'd find at least one other
one yeah so he was like picking
different places and that was like his
dumping ground for those months or
whatever and he would just like go and
dump them there we know he's he's having
sex with a dead bodies I mean he admits
this yeah so maybe he'd like to have sex
one dead body and look at another one it
could be yeah so maybe that's what you
know he maybe didn't want to say that
but that might be what the cluster is
all about yeah maybe he liked it like he
thought it was an audience was almost
groups because they like group sex
between days yeah well and because and
this might be significant to is that
after they caught him when they
interviewed like his ex-wives and his
girlfriends and stuff like that they
said one of his big things was he liked
to have sex with them out in the woods
or in public like he liked to be watched
yeah so maybe that's something to do
with it right
I hadn't thought of that but yeah that
sounds so two weeks after you got put
yourself in the place the perv
yeah I gotta put you so I have a hard-on
I guess which I guess that's good I'm
just trying to think you know you know
me I'm not another dead women try to
imagine you know what I mean what's this
guy what is this guy getting off into so
I'm trying to imagine these women as you
know what what I would be into which is
like living hot women you know right
yeah well as four of them you know yeah
it's me and these four checks you know I
mean it's yeah like a horror movie
yeah I mean but the in his twisted mind
though it's it's better that it's four
dead ones because they can't the answer
back well he can imagine the situation
to be whatever to be whatever he wants
because you know when you know who'd
Gary Ridgway is he's a [ __ ] little
weasel yeah all right yeah I mean he's
he's not even intimidating yeah I would
beat that dude to death yeah okay there
was somebody had that's just the little
[ __ ] you don't mean he the cop said I
mean I saw the damn video of his of his
initial interviews interrogations really
what they were but they call him
interviews and you could just see the
fear inside Ridgway when that gwenna
cops just starts questioning him the
dude is just melting you don't I mean if
he just the dude was a [ __ ] beta big
time beta
and the cops I mean I remember the cops
you know comment and they said that they
were just surprised about what a weak
man he was he was just very very weak we
well well yeah what I was when I was
watching the documentaries a lot of them
said like the first time they saw him
they were surprised yeah um which to me
is very weird because it's always kind
of like what like what do you expect
them to look like a werewolf or like
really big you don't really see
I mean serial killers not all I mean
with the possible exception of Edie
Kemper you don't usually see serial
killers as they're not usually big burly
dudes they're usually just regular
they're either small or they're just
like regular normal-looking dudes that's
what makes them so scary well you see
because they look like a normal person
you see all these dead bodies and all
its damages this dude is done you know I
mean you're a cop and you're seeing all
these bodies you know and in your mind
you're expecting [ __ ] Jason that's
what I mean it's like I can't you'd
think they'd know better but I mean I
guess I can understand the psychology
behind it but you like this because
you've built up you don't know who it is
for years and years and years are built
up he built up all this [ __ ] in your
name or what this guy might look like
and then you finally see him you're like
it's that yeah because a lot of the
detectives said that they're like that's
him yeah it's like they couldn't believe
it because it's like they said he looked
so normal like and he was you know he's
kind of small he's kind of a small dude
and they're like and then he acted
normal they said he acted - they said if
you didn't know that he was a serial
killer it's like you probably liked the
guy he seemed totally nice normal it's
like he just seemed like a completely
normal person he had a job he had a wife
he had everything he had a kid he's you
know all on me
no I'm just saying they're they're like
in general you would never guess that
that day senior he seemed he seemed very
beta very meek and pathetic
that's just waiting and he would look
him he was just like and he was in
horror of being around those cops
yeah he was in horror that's kind of
funny he doesn't hate yeah you're like
dude man you've done all these crimes
you're not ready to [ __ ] face the
police don't kill you
it is terrified you I don't even think
they think of it because like Bailey you
know like I said Gary Ridgway
particularly was not a smart person um I
think he really did not seem
I mean prostitutes to him were he just
hated them there was objects to be used
he could do whatever he wanted to them
and he said as much
in those very words so you know he said
that's what I know I'm just saying I
don't think he saw them as people so
it's almost kind of like that
[ __ ] was lying if you asked me
you know what I think happened I think
first of all I think those hookers
dominated him that's what I think I
think they pushed him around and then he
got [ __ ] pissed off and snapped it
would kill him
that's what I think happened I think
this hook those tough ass hookers that
see that weak [ __ ] and just kind
of boss him around and push him around
he said I mean you think he can clean me
around yeah and he kills them that's I
think really happy it could be I you
can't trust these dudes to tell truth
well that's true all right you just you
can't trust men tell the truth yeah I
think they I think what they did is they
saw the guy is just a mark and would
start pushing him around dominating him
he'd probably go through with it you
okay and then [ __ ] I'm a killer you
know it seems like it does seem like
what he used that though to his
advantage like they said that's why it
was so easy for him to pick up women
because he's a Thomas like he looked
harmless and also another thing that he
would do too
he would do like Bundy would do where he
would like show a picture of his kid he
did have a kid that wasn't [ __ ] so
so he would like disarm them severely
look I'm a family man I wouldn't do
anything to hurt you or anything like
that so he was aware that that's how he
was coming across and that's how like he
did kind of like cultivate that like to
get them to get in the car with him I
just got a feeling that I got a feeling
that they bossed Ridgway around I just
think they did maybe and then anger
would build up Niek any kill yeah that's
I think we have yeah sure I'm a man you
know I mean I'm one of those kind of
guys yeah yeah little fragile yeah yeah
that's what I think
just saying and I'm there I have a
feeling yeah I have a feeling that's pro
but you know looking at him and seeing
his mannerisms I think that's a it was
like that yeah you know these girls were
streetwise huh really wasn't although a
lot of the girls he picked up were young
they were young yeah but he's got like a
hey lemon yeah 15 16 you can handle that
man you know I mean yeah so so a lot of
them were as you know hardened I think
by the time he got to those he is he was
already experienced killer yeah I think
he started off at [ __ ] tough ass
[ __ ] broads push them around in EM
yeah I'm gonna kill you yeah and then he
started seeing them all like that it's
probably something like that yeah almost
kind of like an Aileen Wuornos but a
male version of it yeah so yes she was
like that she was started off as a
victim and then she became perpetrator
she became killer yeah yeah we haven't
done her yet either yeah we gotta do
that I was on yeah she's from around
here well yeah I've driven past the bar
where she used to hang out that she tell
she hung out in daytona like and i grew
up there
yeah that hotel in Daytona where she
used to live at we had to drive up there
and do show that also this is the hotel
actually we probably should yeah I mean
will we live literally like 25 minutes
away from Daytona and like I said I was
born there I grew up in Daytona Beach so
everybody knew about a lenoir knows yeah
cuz she's still hang out there so we
knew some I knew some people that like
kind of knew her or had seen her around
before she got arrested so two weeks
after Kimmy Kimmy's body was found the
Green River task force increased by more
than half they recruited like way more
officers because there were so many more
murders happening in the area so at this
point the official count of Green River
victims because like I said now there
had been like a lot of disappearances
but some of the bodies had not been
found yet so at this point the official
count of the Green River victims was 11
or 12
however there were there had been 18
bodies found in this particular area why
some of these were considered official
Green River Killer victims and some of
them were not is not entirely clear but
at this point
teen bodies and many many more
disappearances which some of whom would
later be found and would be attributed
to the Green River Killer also alright
so we are probably yes we are at the our
mark right now so let's take a break so
we can refill drinks try and find the
kitty various other things when we come
back we will talk some more about Gary
Ridgway okay the Green River killers
will be back in just a few minutes oh hi
sweetie
jump up on my desk you jumped up on
Mama's desk yeah
how you doing little one how you doing
this morning oh you're such a good girl
such a good girl look at her little butt
sticking up in the air your butt is so
funny I don't know why oh my goodness
how can we sleep you just got up you
just got up yeah yeah
where you going are you going oh my
fingers in there don't eat please don't
eat that okay
no chewing on metal okay that's bad for
your teeth juice flooring yes Lauren I
see you exploring you're gonna climb all
over the desk yeah look it oh my god her
tail your butt just makes you laugh I
don't know why you know the funny is but
ever yeah please don't eat that please
don't eat that don't you like your
chicken to sticks anymore I bought you
all those two sticks you don't even chew
on them how much you're gonna eat the
paper you eatin paper what you're doing
not your dog okay
you're just gonna chew on everything I
see you're in a chewy kind of mood
you're in a chewy kind of mood yeah yeah
okay well that pellman's or I could pet
you alright alright here we go
you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry babies case the
Frog boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
okay we're back talking about the Green
River Killer
aka Gary Ridgway tom has refilled his
drink yeah it's weak though we found out
where the kitty got away doing nothing
yeah she's like I don't know why why
would you Josh yeah well you know I
didn't want her like going over to hang
out cuz the neighbors are there barbecue
they're over there barbecuing they know
but they know about her though we got
new neighbors they moved in next yeah
they just moved in the other day so we
were kind of like hey if you see a
little gray kitty with a stumpy tail
she's ours and she likes to like hide in
other people's bushes yeah so don't be
alarmed but yeah so okay so January of
1984 the Green River task force comes
under the leadership of a new guy
captain Frank Adamson now he was
previously the head of the internal
affairs unit and he took a lot of the
recommendations of Bob Keppel who had
said you know you need to like whip this
[ __ ] into shape like get everything
organized and stuff like that so he's
kind of the one the one that won he
moved to task force closer to the
airport so they would be closer to where
most of the bodies had been found the
more recent bodies had been found he
also like made everybody like took all
the detectives and stuff like that and
put them in teams and they each had a
task rather than having everybody run
around like chickens with their heads
cut off like trying to do all things at
once so everybody had their own job and
everybody knew like what the structure
was so so that seemed to like improve
they also kind of went through a lot of
these suspects and we're trying to put
them in groupings like you know the a
group which was like most likely
suspects B group which were kind of like
oh maybe and then C group which was like
maybe not but we're still gonna like
look out and stuff like that they also
started like monitoring the strip you
know more closely like keeping tabs on
all the prostitutes and stuff like that
to make sure like they knew where they
were going and all this other kind of
stuff so they kind of got like all of
their [ __ ] together so you know even
though it seemed like they still weren't
catching anybody and they didn't really
seem that much closer to catching
anybody they did kind of have a profile
of the guy
they did kind of determine some patterns
and things like that so you know they
were kind of you know working and
getting [ __ ] done so however what ended
up happening then was on Valentine's Day
of 1984 they found yet another body the
skeletal remains of a woman who was
later identified as Denise Pledger
now she was actually found 40 miles from
the city near Interstate 90 so she was
the first victim to be found that year
but there would be more to come over the
next two months nine more bodies would
be found like it it just kills me that
it's like this is only a couple of years
I mean it's like 1982 to 1984 was kind
of like when he was the most active and
within like a couple of months he's
killing like nine people yeah you know
what I mean so this isn't some guy
that's like killing one and then like he
takes like a few months off he's like
you didn't regularly regularly like kill
and and like I said I think probably
he's killed a lot more women and they
just never found them to be honest with
you he didn't know how many killed he
didn't he said he lost count and I
believe it I believe it is about 70
that's what he thought he thought it was
71 um that's what he said he was
ultimately charged with 49 um you know
that they that they actually had other
corroborating evidence other than just
his confession you know to suggest that
he had done it but of all the ones he
was saying it was more like 71 and that
would not surprise me if that was the
case funny is that these dudes can do
this and forget how many that how many
it was and not really and be able to
sleep at night yeah like it was no big
deal yeah it would be like they're
closing in on me they're gonna get me
any day yeah he really didn't seem
bothered no like I said he had a family
he had you know he had a wife he had a
kid he had a job he had the same job for
like 30 years I guess he was just too
simple to even worry about it
they'll never do never catch me I kind
of feel like maybe that's what it was I
never catch me you know because he
really seems kind of unconcerned yeah
even when they caught him who she's kind
of like they will never know he's one of
those guys but you know I'm smart for
them but yeah it seems like the Dumber
they are the smarter than back there but
uh cuz I guess if you're done when that
dumb know he's killed 70 I'm and got
away with it for a while true but like I
said I don't know if that's entirely
intelligence or if like some of it's
just luck and like I said because it's
hard to investigate his MO a killer that
yeah just killed doesn't have any yeah
not an action and I think he looked at
it or thought of it that way that was
just the only way he could do it yeah
those are the only women that could get
in his car yeah yeah no I think he just
yeah I think you just went out because
it was easy yeah it wasn't a master plan
although he did have a thing for
prostitutes his dad had as well yeah
well kind of get into it but yeah so
they did find like some distinct
patterns that had emerged in these
particular crimes as I said before he
seemed to have several dumping grounds
they found five of them with clusters
they said pretty much all the bodies
except for Mary me and the the pregnant
woman they were partially buried or were
just laying there like covered with
garbage or leaves or something like that
she had been fully buried they actually
interestingly the where all the bodies
were found they said when they mapped
them out it made kind of like a rough
triangle shape so they thought probably
the killer lived within that triangle
somewhere because he was obviously very
familiar with the area because a lot of
the places where he dumped the bodies
were sort of remote like not like
someone that was just driving through
there would be able to find now when
they found some skeletal remains of some
of the victims in April of I believe
1983 or 1984 they also found some shoe
impressions so that was some more
evidence they said they were walking
shoes size 10 or 11 so that was
or physical evidence that they could to
kind of keep now this was kind of an
interesting anecdote that I read by I
don't think they mentioned this on the
documentary but I found this on like the
serial killer library or something like
that so apparently in mid-april of 1984
there was a woman who was working as a
volunteer for the task force and she was
also a psychic or so she claimed her
name was Barbara Kubik pattern and she
actually had a vision that another
woman's body would be found near
Interstate 90 so she called the cops and
told them about this vision the police
understandably didn't really do anything
about it so the woman and her daughter
decide they're gonna go out there and
look for a body themselves so following
her intuition and you know what she had
seen in her vision her and her daughter
went out to look for a body and guess
what they found one but it's like I
don't know if it was because she was
really psychic
or fish there were so many [ __ ]
bodies that it she was like inevitable
that they would find it if they looked
in that area I don't really know so so
yeah they did find a body they went to
they drove to like where the the cops
were looking for like other bodies like
in another part and they were like um
hey check it out then we found one the
police didn't believe them so they
actually went to you know and they and
the cops were like you know get it this
is like a restricted area cuz we're
looking for bodies to get the [ __ ] out
of here a whirl brush you so she got mad
so she went and talked to reporters and
said hey we found a body over here want
to go get the scoop or whatever so after
that and the cops were like okay fine
we'll come look and then they can came
and found the body
now these remains were completely pretty
much completely decomposed these belong
to a woman named amina agra chef now she
was very unlike the regular victim
profile she was 36 years old much older
than most of the other victims she was
not a prostitute she actually worked at
a restaurant in downtown Seattle and had
last been seen on July 7th 1982 just
walking down the street after work and
had vanished after that he's gay
ride home so whether she was a victim of
the Green River Killer or that's kind of
still debatable because she was really
not she was really not the victim
profile however that doesn't mean that
he didn't just see an opportunity if she
was just walking home from work he never
met a killer
um that one I'm not really sure
she also I mean she had two kids she was
I don't think she was married but she
had like a steady boyfriend at the time
so she wasn't like a transient or
anything like that she had like she'll
do that person so so she's so that one's
like question I bet you he didn't do
that and also the body I mean they did
find another Green River Killer victim
out in that area because this was like
40 miles away from you know the normal
dumping grounds but they did find
another body out there in that same area
that they think was Green River Killer
so it could kind of go either way it
does seem strange that she did not fit
the victim profile at all really um but
it's not impossible I mean maybe he was
just driving around he had killed
another prostitute and he just saw
another woman walking around I said hey
I'm gonna get her - maybe he thought she
was a prostitute - who knows I don't
know but I don't know maybe not and she
seemed really a prostitute we'll go
willingly with you to a location that's
secluded and you can kill her
yeah that's what Gary was into that he
knew he could do that yeah seeing some
girl walking down the street hey you
need to ride home you know and then yeah
sure she gets in the car and then he
starts driving her out to a remote
distance she's gonna [ __ ] split yeah
you know I mean yelling and screaming
caused all kind of Noah's jumping out at
the [ __ ] every stoplight wouldn't
work he didn't do that one it was
somebody that knew her killed her I bet
maybe maybe someone was stalking her so
it was alright there's somebody that
from the restaurant yeah it could have
been like a normal customer that she
knew like I said it you like a lot of
cuz a lot of the ones that happened when
we did that show about like um Toronto
Ontario I think like a lot of those were
you know particularly there was ones
where like the girl like worked at some
store and like all these creepy old
dudes would like hang out in there so I
feel like there's especially if you work
somewhere and you're kind of pretty and
like you get these regulars that come in
and they're like creepy I'm watching you
and stuff so I feel like that kind of
situation probably so that maybe is what
happened in this she is kind of
considered a Green River Killer victim
because the mo was very similar and she
was found in the place of you know very
similar to the place where another body
was found - but like I said because the
victim profile was so different and some
you know some people have expressed
doubt over whether Gary Ridgway killed
her or not so May 26th there were two
kids playing out on a road called Jovita
Road and they discovered yet another
skeleton this was a 15 year old girl
named Colleen Brockman she was a runaway
so this is like pretty much I don't even
know how many bodies were right now so
at this stage following Brockton the
discovery of Brockman's body it seemed
like the murders were slowing down um
you know I mean they weren't finding as
many because you have to think that like
I said some of the disappearances like
some of the bodies that they found were
like of women that had disappeared like
years before you know what I mean
so it's kind of like it seems like a lot
of bodies are being found but not all of
them had been killed that recently like
some of them it was like the year before
or several months before or something
like that but so at this stage the
murders seemed like they were kind of
winding down a little bit
so but the task force was still kind of
going full-bore they now in August of
1984 they had two inmates in San
Francisco they were in jail in San
Francisco and they confessed to the
Green River murders
however police got super excited about
it but then they went down there to
interview them and determined that they
could not have been responsible that
they were just like I guess they just
wanted to get famous or whatever several
months after that Ted Bundy who at this
point was in his cell on death row he
offered to help out in the investigation
he thought he could give some insight
into because he was kind of from that
area as well he was in Florida at this
point obviously
because he was in prison but he thought
he could give some insight into the sky
and maybe help with the profiling and
stuff all of a bottom-feeder
yeah he called him a bottom-feeder yeah
so obviously they weren't gonna fly
Bundy stupid ass like it's a [ __ ]
Seattle but they he kind of communicated
with the task force
it's like letters and phone and stuff
like that so Bundy thought that whoever
this killer was because like I said they
didn't know who he was at this point he
said that I think that the killer knows
these victims at least by sight or is at
least kind of friendly with them this is
somebody that frequencies prostitutes
has befriended them they have no reason
to fear him obviously Ted Bundy also
seemed to think that just like this
killer has probably killed a lot more
people than the bodies that you have
found and that probably you will never
find all of them he also believed that
the the pattern of the disposal of the
bodies were kind of getting close to
where the killer lived because like I
said it seemed like you know Green River
and then it was like the airport and
then it was like you know that Lake or
one of like Star Lake or whatever so Ted
Bundy thought that you know the body
dumps seemed like they were getting
farther away but he's like I think
they're getting more toward where he
lives
because he thought that when the killer
first started killing he was going
farther afield to dump the body so they
wouldn't find it but he was getting more
confident so he was getting closer to
his house was it true um I'm not really
sure because where they found him uh I
don't really know I'm not familiar with
the Seattle area so I'm not gonna I'm
not really sure like how close where he
lived was to where the farthest bodies
away were so even though like Ted Bundy
he was kind of like a big consultant on
the case and everything like that and
helped with the profiling but he didn't
really like help all that much because I
feel like they already had a profiler
yes the profiler is not a theory
killer and sometimes serial killers have
more of an insight into stuff than maybe
someone who's not a serial killer but
I'm not really sure how helpful he was
in the investigation a good cop could do
the same thing and I mean and although I
mean something good did come out of it
because during the course of him like
helping out with the Green River
investigation he did actually confess to
some other murders that he had done so
they so they got some closure there so
that was a win you know what I mean even
if he didn't really help in this
investigation so even though it seemed
like the murderers had kind of been
winding down or were not as frequent
they actually had not stopped entirely
between October and December of 1984
there were two more bodies found these
were Mary Sue Bello who was 25 and
Martina author Lee who was 18
both of these bodies were found off of
Highway 410 so at this point the total
body count is 31 although only 28 of
them are on the official Green River
murder list 14 women are still missing
at this point
March 10th 1985 another partially buried
body found a near star Lake Road this
was 15 year old Kari Royce she had
disappeared during the summer of 1983
mid June
there was a man bulldozing a patch of
land in Oregon of all places and he
found the skeletal remains of two more
women
these were Denise Bush was 23 years old
and surely Cheryl who was 19 years old
both of these women were known
prostitutes from Seattle so the fact
that they had been found in Oregon over
the state line kind of gave police pause
but because both of the girls were from
Seattle and because the mo was very
similar these they pretty much thought
that this was the same killer and that
the guy was trying to confuse the police
by going over state lines and dumping
them farther away now at this stage and
like I said Ian Brady in this book in
this book where he talks about the Green
a killer who had this at that stage had
not been caught when he wrote it he
believed that this was more than one
killer now at this stage famed FBI
profiler John Douglas he started
thinking that maybe this was more than
one killer as well
he's like he believed he's like these
killers are similar like have similar
psychologies maybe one is a copycat of
the other but he's like the ways in
which they are disposed of the bodies
are disposed of are slightly different
he's like because it seems like if this
is two killers that one of them was
going to more of an effort to conceal
the bodies than what the other one was
doing you know some of them were buried
or left in isolated areas are covered
with leaves or garbage or something like
that where some of them were just kind
of left out in the open and this was
even going back to the first bodies that
they had found like opal Mills for
example was just found laying on a
riverbank they didn't nobody tried to
bury her or covering her with anything
the other two bodies that they found at
the same time had been like in the water
so he's kind of thinking that maybe this
is more than one killer operating like I
said I don't know I don't know if that's
the case or not or if Gary Ridgway did
indeed do all of these and just like
changed up his methods like I said
that's not impossible so even though
it's this seems like a plausible theory
you know they didn't really have any
other evidence to support that other
than the slight differences in the MO
and in the way the bodies were disposed
of now at this stage you know this
investigation had been going on for more
than three years the case had gone cold
they didn't really have any new leads
you know the public was getting
increasingly annoyed with the task force
for their seeming inability to catch
this killer so it's kind of like all
sort of coming to a head now a winter of
that year they found the skeletal
remains of three more victims the first
of these was Mary West
she was found in a wooded area in Seward
Park in Seattle the other two were Kimmi
Capet sir who had disappeared previously
and yet another unidentified white
female believed to be between 14 and 19
years old now I think I mentioned before
that Kimmy's Kimmi Pitts sirs body had
been found previously in December of
1983 but her this was interesting too
because her body and her skull were
found in two separate places and they
don't think animals did that they think
the killer did that for whatever reason
they don't know why he took her head
elsewhere but yeah so that seems very
strange that they had found the skull
and then they found the rest for body
somewhere else in a ravine well you know
you know what that was all about yeah
well they might have been pulling about
yeah buddy used to do that all time yeah
that's true that's right you know yeah
it's all that head pleasure yeah Ted
Bundy yes yes he [ __ ] em he liked hey
he liked heads literally you'd like to
get head yeah
which maybe I don't know you could put
it in a refrigerator and keep it over
period weeks me I guess that's I guess
this is [ __ ] up to say but I guess the
portability was lack turn yeah but Gary
lived it at home with his wife he
couldn't take that home true although he
did say that he had murdered some of the
women at the house so hmm I don't know
well because he had three wives like
over several years so maybe it was
between wives or maybe maybe he had ice
chests hidden out there it's possible
sure you ever think of that
yeah but ice chests out there yeah you
might have to put the head in there like
that yeah cuz I mean none of his wives
ever seemed to like and when they caught
him like he was married to his third
wife Judith and she was like completely
shocked yeah she's like she never would
have imagined she's like he was like
it's such a nice guy she like never
would have imagined he was a serial
killer she can't believe it
but yeah so she didn't seem to have any
idea what's going on none of it none of
his wives really seemed to have any idea
what he was up to but yeah so
let's see so February 1986 the Green
River task force they thought they
caught the Green River Killer so they
bring him into the police station there
was like a big media frenzy about
everything though they finally caught
the Green River Killer and stuff like
that but the more they interviewed him
the more they realized this was not him
so the public like I said are getting
really really [ __ ] pissed off that
they can't catch this guy they keep
bringing these suspects into custody
it's like there's big brouhaha gets made
about it's like oh we found him we found
him and then they turn out it's not him
you know they'd had the taxi driver they
had had that Clark guy who was you know
he was a rapist so at least I got him
off the street but it's like you know so
the it seemed like I mean to the public
it seemed like nothing was getting done
and everyone was getting really
frustrated so you know and they started
seeing them as like a joke they weren't
like taking serious taking them
seriously anymore you know and it's and
is if that wasn't bad enough that summer
they found skeletal remains of yet three
more women they found these off of i90
of Seattle
these were Maureen fini who was 19 Kim
Nelson who was 26 and another young
woman who is unidentified
these were Maureen fini was the only one
with a record for prostitution the other
two were not you know the one was
unidentified obviously but the other one
didn't have any record of prostitution
so at this stage its victims are almost
40 at this point that's how many of them
there were so by the end of 1986 even
though they had been finding more bodies
because the investigation was not going
anywhere they didn't have any new
suspects new leads or anything like that
so they started scaling back the task
force they reduced the staff by 40% the
head of it Adamson was like reassigned
to another project so you know at this
stage they're just like they're still
trying to catch the guy but it's just
kind of like it's gone on so long that
they just they have to go to other time
you know there's other crimes that need
to be investigated so they
like spend so much time and they just
feel like they're spinning their wheels
so they get another guy in to head it as
soon as he comes in they find two more
bodies in December these were actually
in Vancouver in British Columbia so they
think like I said this seems to be a
deliberate move by the killer to confuse
the investigation by taking the bodies
farther afield they found actually
alongside these two bodies they actually
found the partial remains of several
other bodies - like no whole ones but
just like pieces of them but they did
even though these bodies were found way
farther away than you know any of the
other victims the mo was still so
similar that they figured this was
probably the same killer so all right so
beginning of 1987 so the cops have a new
suspect this suspect was previously
known to police he had been picked up
attempting to solicit an undercover
police officer who had been posing as a
prostitute this was back in May of 1984
this guy had been released after they
gave him a polygraph test
asking him if he was the Green River
Killer and he passed it however when
they started looking into his background
and his past they actually discovered
that he had been accused of choking a
prostitute in 1980 near the SeaTac
International Airport now in this case
he didn't get in trouble because he said
that the prostitute bit him and that it
was just self-defense like he was just
defending himself because she had
started it so I guess they bought that
so he didn't get in trouble so one of
the guys on the task force whose name
was Matt Haney he thought this dude was
very suspicious so he's like well I'm
gonna go I'm gonna take a deeper dive
like into this dude's background so he
found out that cops had actually stopped
and questioned this guy back in 1982
while he was in his truck with a
prostitute now the prostitute
that he had been with when the police
stopped him was one that later turned up
dead
Kelly McGinnis so they had actually
approached him again in 1983 and this
was the case where Murray mal var had
disappeared and her boyfriend slash pimp
had seen her getting into a truck and
had found the truck later and they had
gone to Gary ridgway's house so this guy
on the task force is starting to put all
this [ __ ] together so he's like we think
that it's Gary Ridgway
so they he starts interviewing Gary
ridgway's ex-wife now the ex-wife says
that he that Gary would often go to a
lot of the places where bodies had been
dumped he started like the task force
guy also started like interviewing a
whole bunch of prostitutes and a lot of
prostitutes when they were shown a
picture of Gary Ridgway did recognize
him as someone that had frequented the
strip during 1982 in 1983 when a lot of
the murders were going on he actually on
his way to work he worked as a truck
painter he spray-painted trucks like in
a factory that made trucks and that he
would go down the strip like pretty much
every day like on his way to work so
they also found out when they looked
into his employment records that pretty
much every day that one of the
prostitutes had gone missing was a day
that he had not showed up for work yep
so hmm
you take a day off go kill a hooker yeah
I don't think he killed every hooker
though no because he because he was like
really into prostitutes yeah I think he
was a regular that yeah he was yeah yeah
so so I don't think he killed every
single one you hooked up because like I
said a lot of the processes when they
interviewed him recognized him yeah so
I'm assuming that you guys with him he
had a reputation for being a good
customer yeah so that means you know
maybe like he only killed one out of
five [ __ ] little tricks he do how
much I bet yeah maybe like I said one
out of ten yeah and I bet you someones
woman he killed he had already been on
dates with them I'm sure and he just
decided he just said I'm gonna take her
to got a while to buy some [ __ ] like
that yeah
I think that's probably what it was
because I do I definitely do think that
he didn't kill everything I still think
it was a beta though and I still think
they kind of [ __ ] dominant dominated
him yeah I think so
sorry Kitty's like and she's sitting
there laying on her back she was very
much I thought she was sleeping her legs
shoot she sleeps like in the middle of
the floor yeah on her back and she's
just like lays on her back with her
little legs just like I think I've got
some video from like some of the old
shows that is a relaxation man has total
trust
it's just it is it's like she's well
that's good though she knows nothing
Bad's gonna happen to her once she
started doing that the other cat Beijing
started copying her yeah I never did
that there they learn until Pookie
started doing it yeah and she's like oh
that looks comfy yeah yeah and it's
funny when Beijing does it cuz Beijing
is like so she's she's a lot bigger than
Pookie but she looks bigger because
she's super super fluffy like a lot of
its hair she's not patterning yes she's
skinny she's actually pretty thin but
she just sounds like a lot of hair so
it's like so she'll accords [ __ ]
hilarious but yes so so yeah so the task
force is starting to get very suspicious
of Gary Ridgway after they've like
linked all these previous you know
arrests and stuff like that together so
on April 8th of 1987 they get a warrant
and they search his house they also took
samples of his saliva and things of
various they didn't really have DNA was
you know yet they couldn't really do
anything with it but they figured you
know we'll just have it like Bron record
just in case like we need it in the
future so they took all that and they
wanted to compare like blood types and
whatever so at this point even though
they searched his house they couldn't
find enough stuff in his house to link
him to the crimes there wasn't enough
evidence to arrest him so they had to
let him go like I said this was 1987
several weeks later captain Pompeii who
was the guy at that point on the task
force in charge of the task force he
actually died from a massive
heart attack related to a scuba diving
accident now the media I guess because
it's like you know how to have a big
story or whatever they tried to tie his
death which was a heart attack to almost
like some other cop it like had a murder
or something like that they tried to
like drum up this big like conspiracy
theory about it or something like that
you know they're trying to call for an
investigation it's like oh was this big
cover-up and she's like that's a reality
right but yeah so it was just a heart
attack I mean the poor guy was probably
stressed out and [ __ ] like that so then
they get another guy in to head the task
force she was Captain Greg Boyle now in
June of that year this is 1987 if you're
keeping track three boys find yet
another skeletal remains of a young
woman this girl was identified as Cindy
Ann Smith who was 17 years old she was
found in a ravine behind the Green River
Community College she had been missing
for three years
damn know so they ended up finding like
a bunch more bodies of women that had
gone missing like in prior years they
ended up finding Debbie Gonzalez who was
14 I'll run away they found Deborah st's
who was 15 she had disappeared six years
earlier so even though they were still
finding bodies these women had been
killed years ago so they don't think
that I mean they weren't finding any
more like recent bodies now in 1988 they
actually found about 20 bodies of
prostitutes in San Diego and for a time
they thought that maybe the Green River
Killer had moved there you know what I
mean so they thought it was the same guy
because it was a similar MO so they
actually like kind of you know liaison
with the San Diego Police Department and
like to see if they could catch this guy
and stuff like that so while they were
doing that they found this new suspect
like I said you know Gary Ridgway is
still on their radar but they're still
they didn't have enough evidence to
convict him so he was just one of many
suspects they were talking about
so one guy that came up during the
investigation when they thought that the
Green River Killer had moved to San
Diego was this guy named William Stevens
now they had done a show about these
murders on that crime stoppers I think I
guess they still do that show do they I
don't really know but you would like you
can call in it's kind of like me what's
that yeah well yeah it's kind of one of
those shows where you would like call in
and like if you recognize the dude or
whatever it's like unsolved mysteries so
um so a bunch of people had called in
and identified him now he had escaped
from prison and had been on the run for
like eight years he had been in prison
for burglary he had been in there for
two years before escaping when the
police found him again he was actually
enrolled at the University of Washington
as a pharmacology student so this guy
had actually previously been
investigated as a suspect in the green
river killings he did not like
prostitutes and did not make a secret of
that he had also told several people
that he wanted to murder them they
searched his house and they found a
whole bunch of guns several drivers
licenses credit cards in different
aliases a bunch of like sexually
explicit like pornographic photos of
like known prostitutes and stuff like
that he actually made his living through
robbery and credit card fraud so for a
time they thought that this guy was the
Green River Killer
so they interviewed him about it they
searched his house this was in summer
and fall of 1989 they searched his dad's
house but they couldn't find anything
linking him to any of the victims now
and as they investigated him further
they also found out that by tracking his
credit card records and stuff like that
that when some of the Green River
victims had disappeared he was
demonstrably like in another state in
another city something like that so they
knew that he couldn't have done most of
them cuz during the months when the
Green River Killer killings were going
on he was actually like kind of
traveling around the country and had
like credit card you know receipts like
to show that where he had been
so in October of 1989 they found two
more young women skeletal remains one of
these victims was Andrea Childers she
was found in a vacant lot near Star Lake
she was actually really decomposed so
they couldn't tell how she had died in
February of 1990 they found Denise
Bush's skull they had found her body
previously in Oregon five years earlier
so this was another case where the body
was dumped separately from the head so
this seemed to be a case where the
killer's like deliberately moving the
bodies around in order to confuse the
investigation so he can't have been that
done now during this time just because
these more skeletal remains keep turning
up these are like old bodies you know
women that went missing a long time ago
and they're not getting any new leads
they seemed to be getting nowhere with
the suspects and everything like that so
at this stage July of 1991 the task
force was actually reduced to just one
guy named Tom Jensen because this had
been you know this task force had been
going for nine years at this point there
were 49 victims they possess you know
they had spent 15 million dollars and
they still had not caught the guy and
everyone was just over it well they
realized that they weren't gonna they
weren't gonna solve this case by police
work yeah cuz he wasn't leaving any
evidence and if so police works all
about yeah he's gonna have to be caught
red-handed or he's got to be caught by a
witness or something so they just said
[ __ ] it we're just gonna sit back and
let him kill until he makes a mistake
that's that's what they were thinking
well what they were actually waiting for
was for that was wrong
DNA technology to catch up that's what
they were waiting for because they did
actually have physical evidence they had
saliva and stuff like that and they had
like a lot of physical evidence like
semen and things like that they weren't
gonna catch him by investigating no well
yeah they had David sub they had found
suspects but none of them know the guy
and like I said they had turned up at
Gary ridgway's house and had
investigated him and they did he was
like one of their prime suspects but
when they searched his house they
couldn't find anything they couldn't
find another they were waiting on
science pretty much waiting on science
are waiting for him to make a steak yep
so yeah this station the task force is
now just one dude you know what I mean
so the case kind of went cold for about
a decade April of 2001 this is almost 20
years after the first known Green River
murder detective Reichert who at this
stage was the sheriff of King County
where the murders had taken place he
decided he was going to essentially
reopen the investigation because he was
frustrated by the lack of effort on it
and he is like god damn it
we are gonna find out who the [ __ ]
doing this because it was kind of
driving him crazy
so he actually formed a new task force
in 2001 and it had six members this also
had a couple of detectives but it also
had a bunch of DNA and like forensic
specialists as well because he knew that
they had all of this forensic evidence
that they had been waiting for the DNA
to be good enough like the DNA evidence
because remember back in the old days
even in the 90s they could do DNA but
you had to if you only have like a
couple of molecules of the DNA it would
destroy it yeah later on by 2001 they
had that thing where they could like
copy like they could make like endless
copies of the DNA so you can't replicate
it so in that sense you didn't have to
like destroy your only you know evidence
I think it's called amplification
something you can clone him into
billions of calm yeah yeah so that's
what it kind of what they were waiting
for because what I was watching like the
documentaries like the investigators
were like we were keeping tabs on like
how the DNA [ __ ] was going because we
did ask them to test these DNA samples
but they said well hey you know this is
like really it was like a tiny bit like
on a piece of gauze like they had asked
Gary Ridgway to like bite into a piece
of gauze so it was like some saliva and
it's like they're like well there's not
really enough of this they're like we
have to destroy all of this to do the
test and you probably don't want to do
that but you know they they did know at
that point that they were trying to work
on making it better so they could like
actually replicate it and stuff like
that so the cops did were aware of that
and they were like waiting for that to
happen so they could like get the
evidence
so so once that came about they started
sending the forensic samples that they
had to the labs now the first samples
that they sent to the lab were the four
the three victims that were found in the
Green River initially this was opal
Mills Marcia Chapman and Carol
Kristensen who were all found on the
same day
these were semen samples so they they
sent these to the lab and as I said
since Gary Ridgway was one of their
prime suspects they compared the DNA his
DNA that they had taken from his saliva
with these semen samples found on the
body now it's interesting because they
had detective Reichert on the
documentary and he said the guy comes in
from the lab with like an envelope and
he's like we got a match and he said
it's Ridgeway isn't it like he knew yeah
that that's who it was gonna be yeah and
he's like he opened it and there was his
[ __ ] mug shot and he's like it was
like a perfect match so guys yep they
got his ass so like I said they did they
had a good idea that it was him they
just didn't have enough to get it they
were just like waiting see he was
[ __ ] sitting back there at his house
just sleeping soundly for all those
decks again decades don't don't over cut
me ya know catch me and ya [ __ ] they
did yeah DNA showed up he didn't even
know that existed
you know he you knows even you know he'd
even know that that was gonna exist yeah
they got ways man catch your ass holy
[ __ ] they got ways yeah it's like nobody
without that in the eighties nowadays
they got [ __ ] electronic ways because
you know all these damn appliances can
probably [ __ ] listen to you I mean
ridges you've refrigerators listening to
you you know there's no telling what
these days they might enact some kind of
damn AI program to just find everybody
who's committed a crime you know just
lock everybody up simultaneously I think
the whole United States a prison like
something out of them okay it's just
like you're all [ __ ] criminals but
it's like a you it wouldn't be any
different I mean if you just made the
u.s. a big prison
like it is now yeah would you [ __ ] you
guys yeah so yeah so um initially when
they arrested Gary Ridgway in November
of 2001 they charged him with for
aggravated murder counts because those
were the ones that with the DNA matches
and they also had other circumstantial
evidence like tying him into those
murders
so um yes so they got him in custody and
they're like all right we are not
letting this [ __ ] go right now
so let's talk a little bit about Gary
ridgway's past like now that they got
him in custody and now funny-looking
little [ __ ] he is kind of yeah so like
imagine Alfred Newman was a goddamn
serial killer how do we know he's not
yeah it's true I just realized that
probably half these people listening are
too young to even know who Alfred E
Newman is does it do for men I know it's
like every time I make a reference I
know every time I make a reference to
like something from the 70s or something
I always think to myself like twenty-two
year old that doesn't mean I can now
although it's I have to say like how
[ __ ] funny it is that I'm always
surprised that sometimes people that are
really young cuz like I was watching
this [ __ ] the other day I was watching a
review of looker like before we did our
review yeah and the guy was talking to
this girl and she was 22 and they said
something about some song and I guess
like the song he was talking about was
bob was by like a Deanne word or whoever
but it's like she immediately went to
Hall & Oates well she was 22 right but
she didn't know the newer song she knew
the old one who all not you so I thought
that was very funny that it's like yeah
I'm just gonna like do the hollowed out
song immediately but didn't know the
name yeah well it's funny cuz you know a
lot of a lot of young people are going
back to the 70s and 80s music you know
because that's kind of like cultural
roots back into that stuff because the
new the new music of today is just
corporate garbage I'm it's terrible well
and - I think a lot of it is oh moshing
that from back then I think a lot of
people I mean because it's the same as
like when I got into like post-punk and
stuff like that in the early 80s um you
know and all these bands that I liked
were like oh we really liked like The
Velvet Underground and stuff like that
so I went back and got into that
stuff because that's what was like
inspiring like you liked so but no a
person that's 22 can go back and like
listen to a u2 album you know like
[ __ ] you know Joshua Tree now it is
yeah yeah you can listen to Joshua Tree
or listen to the dream or an album or
you'll is it almost seems like it
doesn't matter
yeah the [ __ ] came out because the other
things just kind of out there yeah and
it's because of the human quality of the
lyrics and everything you can still
relate to it yeah it's it's you know
it's a lot more relatable it's not a
timeless yeah yeah it's more relatable
to than like damn corporate garbage
that's coming out that doesn't have any
content in it I mean when I was kid
hasn't listened to Jimi Hendrix that was
way before my time true like I listened
to the doors that was way before me yeah
I was really into the Beatles when I was
a kid and that was like because because
my dad really likes them and I really
liked them too yeah it was before I go
back and listen to Led Zeppelin and [ __ ]
and I was thinking about oh man this was
anxious yes that's only like 10 years
old I know it seems like it was so funny
because like yeah when I was like
getting to the Beatles and suddenly I'm
like we're gonna too old yeah yes I mean
I liked it was like yeah but it was only
like 10 or 20 years old at that point
it's like really funny to think about
but yeah so yeah so Gary Ridgway he was
actually born in Salt Lake City Utah and
I know you're what you're thinking but
no he's not a Mormon he's actually about
just so he was born in 1949 he was the
middle of three brothers when he was
arrested he actually worked for a
computer company but prior to that for
30 years he had had a job as a truck
painter at the Kent Worth truck Factory
in Renton Washington so his parents it
seemed like he had like kind of a weird
upbringing um he had his mom a lot of
serial killers have this his mom was
very domineering um neighbors also said
that she was real she was an attractive
woman but also that she wasn't like one
of the one of the women that they
interviewed on this documentary was like
a schoolmate of Gary's brother like
older brother and they knew Gary cuz he
was just like the younger brother you
know what I mean because he was like the
quiet one like that oh the older brother
was like more friendly and
going so she said that their mom was
like not like any of our moms because
it's like she had this really big
bouffant it's like she wore all this
makeup and she were like kind of
provocative clothing let's put it like
that
they're like she always wore like little
tight short shorts and like really
low-cut shirts and stuff like that and
they think and I think Gary Ridgway
actually kind of admitted this that he
almost had kind of like a sexual
attraction to his mom but also he kind
of hated her you know what I mean so it
was like this really weird conflict
because yeah it definitely did seem very
much like that
and also she seemed like I mean her
husband fought all the time Gary Ridgway
was a bed-wetter as a lot of serial
killers are you know that's a very
common thing from their childhoods is a
lot of them are bed wetters and what
would happen is when he would wet the
bed when he was a kid like his mom would
come in immediately and get him and put
him in the tub and wash him like in the
middle of the night and like washes you
know balls and stuff and I guess that
that's what my sexual rich it became
like kind of a thing because I think
like one of the one of the people that
was interviewed for the documentary they
said that one point when this was
happening like his mom's robe fell open
and she was like naked under there and
he was kind of like sexually aroused by
that how do they know about that and
also I guess he said about it right so
he had like this really weird kind of
like sexual fixation on his mom it's how
old was he when this is gone I'm not
really sure I guess he was pretty young
okay um but so he had like this really
weird like relationship with his mom
where he kind of committed because a lot
of the neighbors said you know she was a
good-looking woman and she would like go
around like in kind of [ __ ] I don't
want to say [ __ ] but you know kind of
you know revealing clothing I guess and
she was that some weird [ __ ] always
trying to look glamorous and everything
that's a weird [ __ ] because I don't care
how good-looking your mom is I mean is I
don't think it's normal to be just
attract it's not normal no I don't yeah
that's kind of weird it yet well it's
just kind of like it's um it's not no
special guy yeah
it's not normal to be attracted to
anybody in your family yeah I mean I
could see maybe cousins cuz you don't
grow up in there but generally there's a
thing where you you are not sexually
attracted to people that you grew up in
a house with even if they're not like
blood relation like if you were adopted
into a family say or stepsisters or
whatever they don't usually that that's
a thing yet I think I read there's some
kind of safety mechanisms yeah that
usually happens usually because because
usually the people you grow up with
psychology related to you and you don't
know they're demystified you don't have
any interest in them yeah and also I
think it's kind of like a safety
mechanism whereby you know you don't
breathe to prevent inbreeding because
you know that obviously causes a lot of
problems but like you said takes a
special person to like special kind of
person so apparently he had kind of a
thing for his mom at some point um so
there was also a thing where his dad who
seemed his dad was like real religious
and I think this is where his where Gary
got his thing about prostitutes because
his dad would always be like his [ __ ]
prostitutes [ __ ] blah blah blah but
then he would go to prostitutes so I
feel like that's kind of where Gary got
that cuz Gary had the same kind of thing
where he thought he was always
complaining about prostitutes like they
were filthy [ __ ] and he complained
about in the neighborhoods but he would
go to them anyway you know what I mean
so what was cheap I guess yeah I know I
said I still gotta read that book too
and like I said you you should read that
book in like I said do you think you
could sustain that over like eight or
ten hours alright good you probably can
do a whole episode like that like I said
we need to do an offshoot show of you
just like giving people a terrible in
place like as BTK like this kind of
advice that BTK would give somebody so
like really really awful Ridgeway made a
lot of mistakes
birds ways made a lot of ectasia steaks
although I'm not I'm not move okay
that's it almost it almost started
coming but but then you're like so when
Gary Ridgway was in school he had his IQ
tested and it was 82 damn dum-dums
arrest so yes so um he actually had to
repeat a grade or two in high school
because of his dumbness yeah um aside
from that though like his schoolmates
10d they said he was real quiet but they
didn't really think they said he seemed
friendly enough like he wasn't super
memorable or anything like that they
said he just kind of faded into the
background there wasn't anything like
that stood out about him like he wasn't
mean or anything like that um however
when he was 16 years old he actually I
guess it was a neighbor boy who was six
and I guess they were kind of playing
like out in the yard and he lured the
six-year-old boy into a bush and stabbed
him in the liver dad the kid survived
and I guess Gary didn't get into trouble
because I don't know but yeah um and
later he said that he just wondered what
it would be like to kill someone he
wasn't really mad at the kid or anything
like that he just wondered what it would
be like so he stabbed a kid but the kid
lived so uh when he was about 18 years
old he was still in high school like I
said cuz he got held back once or twice
he actually ended up joining the Navy he
after graduation he married his high
school girlfriend whose name was Claudia
barrows he ended up actually going to
Vietnam he was on board a supply ship
and he did actually see combat I believe
he was in the Army for two years so Navy
and Army or in that in the Navy for two
years running for two years yeah that's
my miss sex so yeah so actually uh
during that period he was probably
drafted no he joined he joined yeah okay
he drew the 80-something Mike you yeah
guess the stands were lower back done in
the Navy I guess they were just wanted
all the people that supply ship you know
depends on what job he was going for our
probably you know probably didn't press
manual labor yeah that's probably moving
boxes and [ __ ] yeah
so while he was in the military he
started spending a lot of time
with prostitutes he had contracted
gonorrhea from a prostitute earlier in
his life however during him while he was
in the military he got gonorrhea again
um he got and this is stupid feels like
so he got gonorrhea a second time and
then he got mad at the prostitutes for
giving him gonorrhea Sheldon that's in
his MO I should have told him even
though you should have work yeah and
then you still kept going and still kept
not using a condom so somehow this is
like the [ __ ] prostitutes fault you
reading into it I'm not reading into it
this is like he's not very typical of
this type of guy he's not killing him
because of the gonorrhea no I'm just
saying that he's got mad I got forgot
she burned me yeah that's what I mean
well he goes back I'm not saying that
I'm not saying that that's what made him
a serial killer and I'm just saying that
it's typical of this type of dude that
they go to a prostitute and have sex
with a prostitute without a condom yeah
and then get gonorrhea and then blame
her yeah you know what I mean with the
dudes dumb I mean yeah dude idiot yeah
now 8585 you're an idiot yeah 82 82
you're knitting a gym a hundred is like
average yeah but a hundred is dumb
dumbest okay that's really dumb that's
me okay yeah hundreds average but that's
pretty [ __ ] dumb you started talking
about 88 there's an interesting 1882
80's [ __ ] dumb yeah really dumb I
think what 60 is mentally chat is
mentally [ __ ] I think I'm not sure
what they fixed yourself is it's
something like this something like that
functionally mentally [ __ ] yeah so
um yeah so he's in the military bang
yell as prostitutes getting gonorrhea
and stuff like that meanwhile his poor
wife Claudia who was only 19 years old
she was left alone at home and
understandably started dating other
dudes
even though Gary was was humping
prostitutes
apparently this made his wife a [ __ ]
though so he could be a [ __ ] but not
her so he divorced her they were only
married for a year or two
so he was actually married three times
his first two marriages were divorced
resulted in divorce because of Affairs
by both partners both him and his wife
now his second wife Marsha she said that
he was violent loved that he had put her
in a chokehold at one point also during
this marriage for whatever reason he got
religion now he had been raised Baptist
and I think his dad was kind of
religious but it doesn't seem like
during his school years he was that into
it however during his second marriage he
really I mean he got full-on into it he
was like reading the Bible every day and
crying over it he was like going door to
door like you know preaching at people
he was like you know hanging out in the
church all the time with the pastor and
whatnot and he was trying to get his
wife to go along with this pastor being
like a you know all the [ __ ] they had
about women in the church and everything
like that so she he was trying to get
her to go along that so he got very very
strictly religious at this point um and
even though he still considered
prostitutes filthy [ __ ] yet he still
kept going to them and as I mentioned
earlier Marsha his second wife and his
other wives and his other girlfriend
said this as well that he had a thing
for sex in inappropriate places like he
was always trying to get them to have
sex like out in public you know where
they might get caught or you know like
out in the woods and stuff like that
and actually a definition yes so
actually my and Marsha said that they
had had sex in a few places where he
would later end up dumping bodies yeah
so that must be nice to find Ron uh he's
like drawn a connection between the two
it's group sex in his mind that's
probably what it is
yeah they also and his all his wives and
his ex-girlfriend's also all said the
same thing that he was sexually
voracious that he would demand sex
several times a day and would get very
upset if they did not comply so he have
limited impulse control yeah they're
talking about
definitely and sometimes you got guys
there they're not mentally all there
that's their main thing yeah I can't
really control impulses is kind of go
with their feelings and this their
feelings feelings dominate them so yeah
okay yeah so I'm operating at a very low
very low level yeah
it does seem like he had very very low
impulse good you know not only in the
you know sexual voracious nough so look
at how many people he killed and how
close together yeah that was gonna be
satisfied
yeah just kid it just seemed like he was
kept picking him up like once a week or
something like that it's just like
[ __ ] hell
so um yeah so and in 1975 he also had a
son by his second wife
his name is Matthew this son when he was
a little kid at one point I think he was
even in the car when Gary likes
solicited a prostitute and also he used
pictures of the kid to you know make the
prostitutes feel better like look I'm a
family man I have a little son like I
said he did have a son it wasn't a
[ __ ] but he used that as kind of
like a use him as kind of like a prop
like to get him to to disarm them yeah
yeah pretty much
so yeah um so there might have been a
kind of thing where because it does seem
like his religious thing that that
wasn't faked that wasn't [ __ ] but it
did seem like it and I think we've
talked about this before about serial
killers that are raised in like really
really strict religious households
I think they have these kind of like
it's it's almost like a self-hatred
because it's like they feel this you
know in in Gary ridgway's case you know
maybe like a sexual like you know it's
being insect insatiable but they feel
like guilts are like a self-hatred about
it so it's almost like a weird like self
flagellation type of conflict going on I
feel like that's probably something it
could be but then again it could also
just be that he's just dumb
well I might be reading into
to it too much yeah I mean it might just
be that he doesn't see any conflicts
between any of this because to see the
conflict you kind of have to understand
Thanks
yeah and when you don't have much
understanding you don't see any conflict
yeah I guess not but it might think he's
a holy church man and he's good and
raping [ __ ] is no big deal well I do
you kind of feel like he might not have
because some of the [ __ ] that he said
like during some of his interviews and
like he said yes you can't believe what
they say like truth everything like that
I don't know if he's smart enough to
like come up with any elaborate stories
yeah anything but it's like some of the
stuff that he said leads me to believe
that he didn't necessarily I'm not
saying that he didn't think he was doing
anything wrong but I think he knew it
was wrong maybe he didn't know why he
was doing it but I don't 1 I don't think
he really knew why I was doing it and
two I don't really think he thought it
was that big of a deal yeah that's what
I was thinking like I I do really feel
like I don't think any insight to I
don't I don't think he saw prostitutes
as people I think he just saw them as
objects and I don't think that he he
didn't feel any compunction about
killing them it's weird because his
third wife Judith like I said who was
married to him when he was caught and
was like completely shocked because she
thought he was just great a great guy
she's like he was totally nice and he
wasn't abusive to her or anything like
that and he actually really did seem to
love her once he married the third wife
it seemed like the murders trailed off
yeah he still killed people but not as
many as he would not be a cut back not
yeah right which is fun stuff to say but
it's like so he did seem to like yeah
she did seem to have some kind of effect
and she did say that to she felt like
she had she's like maybe I actually
saved some people because he would have
killed more people if I had been around
which probably would have been the case
you know what I mean my god I kind of
suspect that were reading into it I
didn't know that he that he didn't he
doesn't that he's just doing what he
feels like doing and he doesn't really
understand enough about himself to you
know I mean yeah but the thing about it
though is that just because a person
doesn't understand why they're doing
something doesn't mean that there aren't
that they're doing it that other people
might be more insightful and be able to
who key goes out and kills frogs damn
eat'em because it's wrong tasty okay
yeah and and then she's just like oh
it's dead and then comes in and just
like hey what's up and forgets all about
it I kind of feel like it that's how
very pretty I thought it's crosses yeah
that's probably what you're talking
about there he's just like he did say
that he hated them yeah and that and
like I said that might have been from
his upbringing because it does seem like
he had his dad had a very similar kind
of view toward it but he was always like
you know blue and filthy [ __ ] blah
blah blah but then he still went and had
sex with them anyway yeah I just you
know and I don't think there's a cop you
don't think he saw any kind of conflict
in that like it was conscious of it but
I do think that there was something like
that psychologically going on I just
don't think that he was aware of it no I
don't think he's wherever I don't think
he was aware of it there's not I don't
think there was much to this guy it's
just mostly just dumb and impulse yeah
and habits and thrills yeah you know I
mean physical thrills killing him must
have been must have been thrilling to
him it must have made him feel powerful
that's all I think but obviously it
wasn't like there wasn't it wasn't very
satisfying it wasn't because he can't do
him it was like really close together I
think it ended up being where it wasn't
a big deal
I think that's exactly what happened I
mean I really think that and he wasn't
even losing sleep over it no yeah no uni
it's like it didn't happen yeah so yeah
so like I said when they interviewed his
wife Judith his third wife she said like
I said she had no idea she said now when
we moved in together they've been dating
for like three years only that they
moved in together before they got
married and she said when she moved into
the house there was no carpet which she
thought was a little weird but he said
oh well my kid was in here and he peed
on the carpet so I got rid of it and I
haven't gotten rid of it and I haven't
like replaced it yet and the cop said
we'll probably he wrapped it Bonnie and
then good so yeah but she late later she
said oh well he used to leave for work
early all the time like he was said that
he was getting overtime like he was
going for all these early morning show
and stuff like that she's like in
hindsight probably he was going and
picking a prostitute yeah [ __ ]
killing of a governor yeah in the
morning can you block it imagine I can't
forget imagine she seemed like a nice
lady
I know one thing deer in his dam during
his interrogations he said he was going
back to some of those bodies and the
cops were doing the math on the dates
and we're we're talking about three or
four weeks and three weeks after the
death he was talking about how to push
maggots aside
yeah a few guys yeah yeah so you know
like three or four weeks and this is
like didn't during the summer and there
she's rotting you know they're like in
and he was like yeah this why'd you do
it well cuz it was free well cuz he
didn't want to have to pay them for it I
think that's why he ended up killing a
lot of them too because he's like he
wanted to have sex in them but he didn't
want to pay for it he's pushing the
maggots aside well yeah he says yeah or
say or they said that like in a
documentary that it's like in some cases
like one of the guys that interviewed
him said yeah he was like he said oh
well after he's like after a while
wouldn't his fungus I had to push
maggots aside and stuff like that so it
wasn't as I asked and he's and the
detective was just like horrified cuz
he's like so he's like he's like he's
just talking like it's like [ __ ]
regular like I'm talking to you right
now is away was a female detective I
wonder how he got that smell off of him
see that's another - like I'm kind of
fast I know this is [ __ ] up but I'm
kind of fascinated by like the practical
concerns of this kind of stuff it's like
great maybe when I was near the water
cuz he would jump and jump in the water
and like me must have taken all his
clothes off I guess so then and then
jumped on them because [ __ ] man if you
did that and then you came home it's
like the second you walked in the door
was like oh my god it smells like a
[ __ ] corpse in here he must have very
distinct you know all them clothes off
he's looking at that rotting body going
oh yeah I'm gonna get me some of that
right there oh yes girl you know talk
about that kind [ __ ] he's taking the
clothes off then he jumps on they're
going to town on it you know just going
swashbuckler on this second right yeah
and then he needy company and then he
gets up you know what I mean it's got
all he's got all that [ __ ] slime on
him and [ __ ] [ __ ] nasty and then he
gets down into water just washes off and
puts his clothes back on must have
brought a bar soap with him did he say
anything about that oh I don't think he
did I wonder if he thought that much
ahead you do have to because
I mean because Judy water isn't gonna
get that smell off I'm sorry to walk
around smelling like a [ __ ] dead body
yeah
and everybody wouldn't everybody would
know what that was I would think you'd
have to bring a bar but he knows what a
dead body smell you think he'd have to
bring a bar soap with you God maybe you
did yeah
that is so [ __ ] messed up man bar
soap some cologne and [ __ ] like that
trying to get all that stuff off you may
be some Palmolive made me like a big old
thing Apollo I've taken you know what
cuz we're talking about you know nearly
a month dead yeah it was like ma it was
like weeks and months yeah like when he
went back there and there might be
another one right near there just even
more rotten you know I mean and that
[ __ ] is a necrophile see he's just not
telling the truth
so he's buried by me was like that to
you it's like he was he he would talk
about killin people but it's like he was
really reluctant to talk about next
dealio because I I feel like he's still
neo that's pretty gross and it's like
really one it's like Oh killing people
that's okay but it's like [ __ ] a dead
body
yeah people might think less of me
because yeah they want to talk about
that you know and we're talking about
these bodies for rotten that's what I
mean it's like I feel like okay like I
can understand like because a lot of
killers that have a lot of serial
killers that have necrophiliac
tendencies they generally have that
because they like to have complete
control over a victim they don't want
some woman watching them they don't want
someone watching them you know to me
because it's like performance anxiety or
so like that but you know I I almost can
see that but when it gets to a point
where the body is decomposed yeah what
are they getting out of it then could be
that what they don't want to admit is
that that's where the real fetish is
that's what I'm saying maybe there has
to be a bit because like I said if you
just have a thing where it's like oh
well I like to have sex with women who
don't who won't watch me or won't like
talk back and I can do whatever I want
to them it's like you would think that
they would just do it when they were
like freshly dead and then stop but the
fact that they go back after the women
are rotten yeah it makes me think that
that was the goal me yeah and they just
don't want to say
I want to say because they know how
girls don't really want what they really
wanted was some chick that was rotten
with a bunch of maggots on them that
that was what turned them on yeah and
like you said maybe they were just like
embarrassed they actually had shame
about that maybe that's what it was it
had to be it's more logical cuz like I
said I can I can see why psychologically
you know having sex with a dead woman
would be appealing to a certain type of
serial killer but not wrong but not
rotten that's what I mean that's a
different that's a different issue I'm
thinking that it was the rotten that
they were that they were into yeah I
kind of suspect that as what kind of
thing i money and I think but and I
think Gandhi was in Bundy was into that
too because and I think that the fact
that he was really into it kind of
played into the fact that he was like
really reluctant to talk about it yeah
he didn't want to look like a [ __ ]
filthy scumbag a janitor he tried to
elevate it because he was trying to be
he was trying to be look how clean cut
and yeah normal I am and chilling trying
to be the Errol Flynn of [ __ ] serial
killers even though he was just like it
was really what it was rotten bodies and
heads yeah you just wanna say it yeah
and I think that's the case with this
guy Jo it's just like this guy he he
seemed to have less compunction about
admitting it
although but he didn't say like he was
into like the rotting bodies he just
like and pride goes back to certain
types of infant ilysm and little kids
playing with dead things
yeah a lot of little odd little boys
will play it yeah I play with dead
things we all did yeah they find a dead
dog on a railroad tracks flipping over
yeah that kind of that's not that
unusual I don't use little girls do that
to you yeah so now and somehow it's
probably like a guy at that stage of
life somehow become sexualized and then
the ten merge to where there's a sexual
arousal by [ __ ] something that's dead
or right when a bunch of maggots in it
yeah and it somehow is linked with kind
of like
a resentment a resentment towards women
yeah it's all kind of merged together
and feelings of inadequacy so you deal
with really somebody who's got the mind
of a perverted child really yeah okay
yeah that starts to make more sense to
me yeah because when when you look at
Ridgeway with like the dam 82 IQ just
the way he is and a bane and [ __ ] like
that you're dealing with somebody who
hasn't really developed mentally it's
like a child yeah like a child on a
railroad tracks playing with a dead dog
yeah
and trying to [ __ ] the dead dog like
that yeah like yeah like you said like
the sex and the death but yeah yeah
intersperse it's at a young age
yeah it's gonna be something like it's
gonna be something more like that I am
so in 2001 as I said he was arrested now
initially they only really had enough
solid evidence to do seven counts of
murder
however he plea bargained they said he
said if I confess to all these other
ones and he actually led them to like a
bunch more bodies and stuff like that
then he would not get the death penalty
so he ended up confessing to initially
48 murders and later another one was in
2003 I believe another one was at it was
49 counts and as I said he did actually
lead them to some of the bodies that
they had not discovered yet so they know
that me you know he probably did that so
um as I said he couldn't get the death
penalty so he got 49 life sentences to
serve concurrently so he will never ever
get a G he's still alive like I said
he's 70 years old and he is in prison as
of this moment in Walla Walla Washington
49 49 murders yeah and he thought that
it was probably more like 71 yeah and I
don't doubt it
no Gary Ridgway I don't doubt it not in
the least so yeah pretty much
he's [ __ ] scum texts we talked about
this show like I said we still gotta do
[ __ ] man we still gonna do Ed Gein we
started doing Wuornos
got a date with John Wayne kid I think
we're gonna do John Wayne Gacy next
month maybe I do makes me mad they all
make me mad it's like you can't do
anything about it but it's like this is
all terrible people and yet and yet it's
like I don't know why I don't know why
it's like a Dean Corll type dude yeah I
think coral was [ __ ] more work I
think he was worse uh with with the
other although they both were [ __ ]
terrible they're bad that's what I mean
it's like woody it's hard getting into
like matter of degree because it's like
they all suck pretty much gay rapist
torturer there yeah terrible yeah that's
like terrible all right so we probably
gone wait long enough and I'm getting
kind of sleepy it's kind of late I
didn't sleep very good last night so I'm
getting tired I'm actually amazed I made
it through the show without [ __ ] up
too bad now you good but yeah well I
have the web meticulous notes that's the
way so I could just read from that if I
couldn't remember what I was talking
about all right so we're gonna wrap up
episode 178 about the Green River Killer
Gary Ridgway hope you guys enjoyed our
rambling discussion and remember if you
like the show like share subscribe on
all your social media tell all your
friends and family about us anybody that
you think might be interested let them
know if you'd like to financially
support the show it would be much
appreciated of course you can go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a button in the sidebar to a
PayPal account that goes right to yours
truly if you'd like to give you a
one-time donation
again much appreciated so that'll do it
for this episode we will see you guys
next time
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]